this is jocko podcast number 261
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
being in the teams
is the best job in the world
probably heard me say that before the
best job in the world
why do i say that why do i say that well
first of all the job itself which
consists of shooting machine guns
jumping out of airplanes blowing things
up
scuba diving running around in the woods
it's just a freaking awesome job so
so you got that on top of that you got
this mission
the mission that you're focused on
you're on a mission to protect
america to protect democracy to protect
freedom to protect people
and in order to do that kill
bad guys because you're supposed to do
all that protecting in order to do all
that protecting
you gotta kill bad guys which
which as a kid and really as a man
for that matter that's what me and my
friends
always wanted to do and i'm sorry if
that doesn't sit right with you
or if you think i'm some kind of a
monster because of it but that
that's the reality
so that's another reason why the job is
awesome but the last thing and certainly
not the least thing
in fact the best thing about the job
by far is the boys
the boys the guys you get to work with
they're they're awesome and contrary to
popular belief there's no
cookie cutter format that represents a
guy in the seal teams
the guys come in all shapes and sizes
they come from all different backgrounds
and it should be noted that not all of
them
are good guys there are some
knuckleheads for sure there's some
egomaniacs
there's some guys that really aren't
part of the team there's some guys that
look out for themselves
there's guys that don't help out there's
some guys that don't care about the
mission
those guys have put themselves above the
team
so there's there's some of those types
running around and that's true in any
organization but as a whole
the boys are pretty legit they're hard
working they're tough they put the team
first
they get the mission done
and they have fun while they're doing it
and you can count on them
which is an underrated thing right you
can count on
them
and i was lucky enough to work with a
ton of those guys during my career
i was leaving ramadi so it's the end of
my
last deployment and i was leaving ramadi
and another task unit
came in to take our place and
they were coming into a complete and
utter
firestorm
of sustained combat
and look we had all been deploying a
bunch
over the years since 9 11 and this was
sort of the end of 2006 and so so guys
knew what it was like to go on combat
deployments
but this particular combat deployment
that we had been on in the battle of
ramadi was significant we had
a lot of casualties
and these guys that were coming to
replace us
i mean i knew that they were coming into
something that seals hadn't deployed
into in a long time and look i'm not
saying that seals weren't deploying into
dangerous places they were but kind of a
known
scenario like that it'd been a while
and so i felt
[Music]
horrible actually i felt horrible for
the new task unit that was showing up to
replace us because i felt like we had
learned so much there
we had gotten good at our jobs and we i
felt like we were leaving this other
task unit in a bad spot
and i was worried
[Music]
about them and worried how they would
survive
well i knew a few of their guys
a few other guys i knew and and that
gave me uh a level of comfort
one of the guys that i knew was the
senior enlisted guy
of the task unit a guy named steve ward
one of one of the good guys and i i kind
of knew him tangently
over the years
because i turned i turned over with him
in baghdad
a couple years earlier he'd been in a
leadership position in a platoon
a team five and to run a bunch of
operations
and done a great job and i'd gotten a
solid turnover from him so that was
awesome
and it just made my comfort level go up
that someone
was coming in that was humble enough to
listen and learn not just from me
not just from tasking a bruiser but also
from the army in the marine corps
and who is also smart enough and
knowledgeable enough
to mix in that knowledge and that
experience with humility and make sense
of the whole
crazy situation
which is what he did and
when steve came back from that
deployment which which was a hard
deployment for them
we ended up working together actually
actually truly working together for the
first time
at tradet the training command
he took over the land warfare training
cell as the senior
enlisted advisor in that training block
and we ended up spending
spending a lot of time together training
and preparing
seals for combat deployments to iraq and
afghanistan
and it was a
i i it's hard for me to even say it was
a challenging job yeah it was a
challenging job
but it was so critical and it was so
rewarding
to be able to work with the young frog
man and pass on the lessons
learned to the next generation
so that they could go out there and take
the fight to the enemy
and keep themselves safe as safe as they
possibly could
and i eventually retired out of that job
and steve carried on in his career
he went on to more senior positions of
leadership and continued to deploy
over and over again in support of the
war on terror
until a few months ago when he
finally retired and
since then we've been working together
again still
still actually training leaders this
time for leadership in the business
world
but we're back at it and it is an honor
to be working with steve again
and it is an honor to have steve here on
the podcast
to tell us about his life his
experiences
and his lessons learned steve thanks for
coming on man
hey thanks for having me i appreciate it
joko you were one of the guys in the
beginning when this podcast kind of
kicked off that was giving me reports
from the field that you were in the game
listening to it
yeah me and gardner were going back and
forth you know
some of the books you covered early on
like the last hundred yards i was like
damn
how could you not get on the net and
listen to that for you know a couple
hours so
it was good yeah and here you are
sitting in that sitting in the chair
uh let's go let's let's rock and roll
let's talk about where steve word
ward came from yep so grew up in
sacramento california
small town um my mom and dad were
divorced so
i'd go see my dad in the in the summer
months and my sister
and my mom and i we all grew up together
in sacramento
um i graduated high school in 91 what
would you slow your roll bro
i got a list of cover man come on so
what'd you what'd your mom do what'd
your mom do for a living
so she worked at a davis college she was
like an administrator there
and then what about your dad where was
your dad so my dad he was an air traffic
controller so he kind of bounced around
the u.s
spent a lot of time in florida puerto
rico up in washington d so did you see
much your dad growing up
yeah in the summertime me and my sister
go and see him for anywhere from two
weeks to 30 days at a time
so it was good well so it could be so
you you just breezed through like oh
went to high school and then graduated
you were about to like be in the navy
did you play sports yes so played uh
baseball soccer and football coming up
any good i'd say i was an average
athlete
nothing special i wasn't consistent i
had good like for baseball i had times
when i was
doing good and then i'd get in a slump
and wouldn't do so good slump
due to bad attitude
slump from um i'm trying to think of a
good way to word this here
slump from not i guess being good enough
you know like you get so i was a pitcher
i played baseball i played pitcher and i
played outfield and i'd have some times
where i'd get up there and
you know my friends would be cracking
jokes at me you're going to beam the
first batter you're going to beam the
first batter first pitch i'm being the
first batter i'm like damn
you know you're not you can't crack
crack jokes up on the mound because you
just hit somebody with a baseball so
you know didn't pan out too good for me
so my junior year i kind of quit
baseball and my freshman year i started
playing football and i really enjoyed
football contact sport
hard like a lot of hard work goes into
that so i enjoyed football finished that
up my
you know senior year i played all four
years um in soccer i kind of quit
playing that when i was
probably like around 13 14 years old
what kind of what what were your friends
doing when you weren't playing sports
getting in trouble getting in trouble so
sports
you know i was probably like uh
i wouldn't say a bad kid but i was
definitely off the path seventh eighth
and ninth grade
not good things for me you know i got i
was picking up trash on the side of the
roads i was on probation just doing
stupid [ __ ]
for what just nothing i care to repeat
on the net
just uh what do they call that
delinquent
i was a delinquent and it wasn't my
friends it was me i was a guy that was
like one when my friends came around i
was the guy
instigating and kind of leading the
charge on doing what kind of music were
you listening to
i just whatever like country rap rock it
didn't matter
just didn't matter we had the old am fm
radios there ain't nothing that's it
going on
there's a different time yeah you were
limited to what you could actually hear
yeah was it a small town um yeah so i
grew up actually in west sac that was
definitely a small town
okay so yeah small town smaller high
school
i went to a high school called river
city um
it was small did they have wrestling
there they had
they started a wrestling program i think
when i was in about 10th grade there i
didn't i didn't wrestle
i played football and i stayed away from
basketball
um yeah how was your grades
look i don't i'm willing to venture not
they were not good i passed high school
by the you know
barely past high school so it wasn't
good for me i didn't pay attention
had good teachers always giving you good
advice i was just not into learning
so you're a little bit of a troublemaker
right do you think when you were being a
troublemaker
do you think you were doing it for
attention do you think you were doing it
for the thrill do you think you were
doing it for adrenaline like why do you
think you were doing it i
i think when i was a truck which i was i
think of a lot of it what i was doing
to sort of prove to myself
and my friends that i was like
uh uh
tough like type things like i don't care
i'll do this like that kind of thing
when i think back
as to why i did dumb [ __ ] which i did
plenty of
i think that's why a lot of it was like
to prove
that i was a quote and i'm putting in
big air quotes here tough because the
stuff i was doing was by no stretch of
the imagination
tough yep i'd say i fall in that same
category trying to prove something just
doing
and i got a journal adrenaline rush out
of doing those dumb things
and it took a long time to get out of my
system so you said that was mostly
sixth seventh eighth ninth grade seventh
eighth and ninth yeah by 10th grade were
you kind of
a little bit more squared away turn on
the corner yes yep did you feel
did you have some run-ins with the law
that kind of straightened you back out
probation and picking up trash on the
side of the road kind of squared me away
real quick you gotta wear the little
orange vest
you're in the van with all the rest of
the delinquents you're on the road on
saturday and sundays
not a not a good situation
not a good situation so then you you
graduate
you barely graduate high school at what
point did you
think about joining the navy or did you
think about the joining the marine corps
the army what where where'd you what was
the situation with enlisting in the
military
so i remember one of our my high school
teachers told me hey you got
three choices when you get out of high
school and he's kind of mentoring us not
none of us know it at the time but he's
like hey you can go to college which i
highly recommend you can get a job or
you can join the military or you can do
a combination of one and two
and that kind of always stuck with me
you know and then as i started going
into college like man i just i don't
want to learn i wasn't ready to learn
wait a second so you just skipped
right to you're in college so you when
you when you're still in high school you
you didn't join the navy or join the
military while you're in high school
correct he gave you the three options
job college
military you chose college yes
first yep you thought all right did you
have
any freaking vision of any kind
whatsoever you're just like no
sign up for whatever classes they signed
me up for yeah so i just signed up for
the basic general education stuff
you know went for a full semester and
then dove into the second semester and
that's where
like at one point i don't know how the
recruiter wound up at our door but the
recruiter wound up on
our doorstep and i started talking to
him and where's the doorstep of what
your
house of the house so you know you go
through and i was like yeah this is
something i think i might be interested
because your mom called the damn
recruiter in center
oh she was kicking him out of there oh
really she was not having
any other recruiters she told him get
the hell out of here
was your mom a hippie or something no no
she's a farm girl
she grew up on a farm yeah she just
didn't she didn't want me joining the
military
but you talked to him i talked to him
and
was he a navy recruiter navy guy yep
navy recruiter did you have
any inkling did you have any parents
grandparents anything about the military
you understood yeah so my grandfather
was in the army
and he was he never went he was around
the world war two air
but he never went and served you know he
got stationed out
uh in alaska somewhere and then my dad
was in the air force
so i had some small touch points there
with some cool stories of
you know grandfather being in the
military he's talking about throwing his
grenade and the sergeant was telling him
that was the best throw ever type thing
and then my dad was in the air force
your grandfather was getting told
you're going to beam the batter with
that girl yeah
whacking so then so the guy
the recruiter talks to you and at this
point you realize college is like
a waste of your time yes i'm done with
school
with school i didn't enjoy high school
and i definitely wasn't enjoying college
at that point which college was it i was
just called sac city
community college so you're and you were
so you were living at home during this
time yes
yep living at home working part-time
going to college what was your part-time
job
man i don't remember what it was i had a
couple of jobs growing up like i worked
in a
a bunch of different little restaurants
being a bus boy being a dishwasher um
move furniture with a guy named craig
who's great family guy and so we'd get
on the road he worked for allied
furniture we'd be trucking on down to
l.a with furniture on the back of his
big old 18-wheeler
it was actually a good job it was hard
work but it paid good money was paying
10 bucks an hour back then that was that
was good money you were kind of the man
with 10 bucks an hour
the man with 10 bucks an hour yeah and
that was a lot better pay than the navy
paid you i'll tell you that
back then so how'd the navy recruiter
convince you
he was just like hey come in and give
this a go man and you know so i went
through did all the asvab testing he's
like all right we can get you in
uh in june timeframe and what what job
were you signing up for because you
didn't list
did you know about the seals at this
point no i didn't i never
i didn't know what a seal was so i just
i was signing up to go to
the regular navy to go on a ship to
figure life out
yup little did i know i was about to get
after some
bathroom cleaning so so
what what like job did he sell you on
he didn't sell me he was just like i
mean so i had
i grew up with some friends and they you
know a lot of people were getting in
trouble people were doing drugs all that
kind of dumb stuff so i just knew i had
the best option for me at that point in
my life was to get out of sacramento
and go try something different so the
job i would i didn't know what i wanted
to do
did you go to did you go ud undesignated
yes
oh damn yeah so i was in so for people
that don't know
like in the navy you have a job it's
called your raiding
and your job is you know you might be a
welder
you might be uh a technician
or an engine man that's going to work on
engines or you might run a weapon system
and they have names for all these
different jobs
but if you don't have a job
they call it and i remember this from
boot camp
it was a threat they'd say you keep this
up you're going to go to the fleet ud
undesignated it means you have no job no
skill you're just gonna go in there
so that threat that i got told was
actually
what you got signed up for go to the
fleet
ud undesignated sign me up i'm ready to
roll
get me out of sack yeah get me out of
here yeah
so you rolled into boot camp yep rolled
into boot camp finished up in uh
i want to say right around october time
frame so went to boot camp when did you
go to boot camp
in july 1991 okay
and then did you go to orlando no no
here in san diego oh you went to san
diego that's right
west coast yep so you went you went to
boot camp and you just went to boot camp
eight week it was eight weeks i think it
was so we went to eight weeks of boot
camp and then
to the fleet oh yeah eight weeks of boot
camp then i went to
semen training because i was gonna work
in deck department that was my own
designated i was gonna be you know
semen so got trained up for three weeks
there and then showed up to a ship
sometime and i think november december
time frame
of 91. bro yeah
hey man it's not that funny
that's crazy dude yeah that's crazy you
must have done good on your ass vabs
that guy didn't try and make you into
like whatever some other rates we could
get more
no that's crazy dude well that's in so
that was probably my first lesson
learned in life hey pay attention
in school so you score good on your
asvab
so you have options right hey when
you're in high school you don't i didn't
ever really thought about that
i just need to make it through but in
life you're going to be given some tests
whether you're going to go
work in a fire department a police
department you're going to go in the
military
and so the better educated you are the
more options you're going to have
available to you
and i didn't do so good so my options
were limited
yeah that's one thing i always try and
explain when like parents
ask me about kids and like what and i
think one of the biggest
things you can do for a kid besides
getting them into jiu jitsu
is making them realize that their
actions today
have impact on the rest of their life
absolutely we get little kids
and when i say little kids i'm talking
me when i was 23
right what i'm doing right now is going
to impact where i'm going to be
right and so how can you expect a 13
year old or a 15 year old
and you know girls might be a little bit
smarter than boys
it's possible it seems judging from my
own children anyways let me let me let
me phrase that because i want to
generalize
in my personal family it seems like my
daughters are a little better at
connecting
what they're doing right now with the
future than my son who just
doesn't do it as much
so yeah that's a good point when you
realize that what i'm doing right now as
a kid
and it's not just kids what i'm doing
right now as a human
is going to impact the way my life goes
and you might end up in the fleet ud
getting after it so so you do eight
weeks of boot camp
three weeks of prep semen prep school
and then boom you go to a ship yep what
was that wake up call like
it wasn't bad it wasn't bad it was
probably one of the best things that
ever happened to me
what in what way yeah just it was it was
a lot of hard work you know it's when
you show up in deck department and
you're an
e2 you're getting every you know uh
you're getting all the assignments that
are not fun to do
you know you're cleaning bathrooms
you're painting the ship you're chipping
paint off the ship you're
you're just doing all the things on ship
maintenance
and so you're eating some humble pie for
breakfast lunch and dinner while you're
doing this
it gave me a chance to to kind of grow
up a little bit it was good it was hard
work
roll the sleeves up and get dirty yeah
you had time to reflect
yeah time to reflect what were you
thinking about
when you were reflecting i was so when
i'm reflecting on that i'm just like hey
man
can make the best out of this situation
so i had one of my buddies that i uh
i went through boot camp with we wound
up on the same ship chris
and me and him just always had
competition we got put in the same
deck department and every assignment
they gave us we're like running up and
down them stairwell ladders just oh
dang competing you know completing
assignments coming back like hey what
else do you got from me like hey you
knuckleheads that's supposed to take you
to lunch time we're like well we're done
give us more
that's awesome man so um it was it was
fun we made the best of it you know and
we had some good
some good leadership on the ship and
some bad leadership you got a that was
my first exposure to
kind of what right looks like what bad
leadership looks like
um so it was good and you're taking down
all these data points and you're storing
it in your head you know
um and probably one of the biggest
things i took out of that
assignment is we had guys that were
super knowledgeable
just very good like we had a bm2 and he
was super good at being a bowser mate he
knew everything how to tie all the ropes
all the maintenance he knew everything
and he was squared away hard worker
looked out for his guys you're like
that's a dude i want to be like um you
know always talk about echelon from hey
modeling the correct behaviors
that dude was modeling all the right
behaviors busted his ass
did good things and he was getting
promoted while i was on that ship so
you're like ah
data point that's what right looks like
same thing with the
handful of chiefs that were on that ship
just good solid dudes they weren't
afraid to
roll their sleeves up get in there with
the guys and get to work
know like all right check mental note on
that
so then how long how long was it when
you were in the fleet until you heard
about the
teams yeah so we had a couple guys that
didn't make it through sale training
they showed up
um became friends with those guys at
some point and they told me all about
you know basic underwater demolition
chill training and i was like damn
that's something i'm interested in so
i started training up they told me kind
of all the things you need to do to be
successful they took me over the
obstacle court
course showed me all the tricks on how
to navigate that thing a lot of
technique
in the meantime i was getting my
application together and submitting
everything so
when i hit the two-year mark on the ship
i'd had my application
back i was approved to go to to seal
training and everything was dialed in as
tight as it could be no matter what i
was gonna have to do two years on that
ship
so you weren't even close to your two
years yet and you already had your
application in
i would say i had it in right around the
probably 13
14 month cycle so you owed whatever
whatever those months were
the other year or something like that 10
months left yep
yep something like that before they'd
release you yeah and the cool thing was
you know we had two
my division master chief was an e9
obviously he was a good dude and then
our cmc our command master chief of the
of the ship was a good guy and they're
like hey man
you work hard you stay out of trouble
we'll make some phone calls we'll make
sure that you get a shot at going to
buds
and they didn't have to do that you know
they could have been like hey pac sand
jack
you want to get off the ship ship get
out of the fleet and go to some other
program that's not helping us out
they didn't do that they looked out for
me you know working hard staying out of
trouble
being a good person all those three
things were were good you know so again
it was kind of like reinforcing good
behaviors um so always be thankful for
those guys
and then uh the guys the the guys that
showed up
that had been to buds what kind of
impression did that give you
did you because there's a weird thing
that somehow you have to think that you
can actually do it right
yeah or you know like for me i was like
i can do this which is a really arrogant
thing to think right it's arrogant to
think
most people quit but i'm gonna be able
to do it yeah
i wasn't sure where i was going to shake
out on the whole thing be honest with
you i didn't like run long distance and
grown up you know we did a lot of
sprints in football um and i wasn't good
with pull-ups
that so pull-ups i was i definitely
sucked at and i was like or i don't know
if i'm gonna be able to do
the amount of pull-ups that are needed
done so i just started working hard on
my pull-ups got on a good running
program
got on a good swimming program those
guys taught me how to do the side stroke
and so you know i just get up early in
the morning knock all this stuff out go
in and either do a weightlifting program
and then
do my cardio at lunchtime or vice versa
and uh every now and then those guys
come over and be like hey dial this in
work on this look at that
so i was i was mentally and physically
prepared for first phase on what to
expect because these guys had given me
so much information
um did those guys talk about what
happened to them
yeah so one of the two of the guys one
of the guys made it past hell week
another guy was in second phase and he
got dropped for a pool comp and then
the other guy he was he got up right
around the third week mark
four week mark in first phase and he got
injured and he got rolled out
guy got dropped for pool comp in second
phase yep and then what would you say
the other one was the one
guy made it past hell week and something
happened when he was waiting to class up
her second phase
and they dropped him and then the third
guy he made it i think to like week
three or four
and then got hurt or quit he got i think
he well he said he got
right yeah so you know no one ever quits
yeah yeah yeah
so you had a pretty good idea of what
you're going into
yep because like i can tell you i didn't
have anybody that i didn't know anyone
that went to
seal training at all you know because i
was in the civilian world
so for me i didn't know what pool comp
was i didn't understand anything it was
just a blank open
nothing and do nothing but you had a
decent idea of what
was going to be coming yep yep i good i
was
i was physically and mentally prepared
for first phase did you get your
pull-ups squared away
i did i actually went in a little better
with my pull-ups and you know the deal
when you show up and you start classing
up
you're starting from scratch again so
now you're from where i came in i was
coming back down uh with you know my run
times and swim times and all that stuff
meaning you were in better shape than
what was required
yes yeah which is the way you freaking
should try and get there yep
yep so you show up to buds did you get
what you expected
yes yeah it was it was full benefit so
it was good times
what class were you in i was in 194. so
we start we classed up i want to say
right around january
of uh 1994. would you have the
did you have problems with anything
in buds yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah so first phase
first phase and third phase were those
came a lot more natural to me you know i
grew up hunting and fishing and shooting
guns and
doing all that fun stuff so third phase
wasn't bad first phase i was mentally
prepared for second phase i'd never
scuba dived i never did any diving and
for me that was the hardest phase
you know i actually failed a couple
events in there like i failed pool comp
the the first go round you know and then
when i did my retest i passed it and
then like
every little thing you know you're doing
ditching dawn you're doing all these
little things with scuba tanks and going
down and doing stuff like i was jacking
it all
up and for me my learning style i really
have to
digest you know what it is i need to do
and kind of like visualize it
and things were on a quick tempo for guy
face
and so it wasn't uh it yeah it wasn't
good for me
did you feel like you were on the bubble
the whole time like when i filled pool
comp i was like all right
damn i'm not going to make it through
this man you know you're on the wall of
shame that doesn't help either you're
like looking at brexit you're like geez
you know i failed pool comp too yeah
yeah
i had our ops guy from trade our ops
warrant officer from trade
put me through yeah full comp
savage yeah he just well you know what's
crazy with pull comp like i'm going
through
and in my head i had the procedures down
and i thought i did good
i'm like i'm down there tying the whammy
not doing all this [ __ ] and i'm like i'm
cool calm and collect i'm
going through the procedures and the
instructor just yanks me up by the tank
she's like you failed get on the wall
and i was like
damn seriously like i'm going through
trying to think of what i
did wrong i'm like i thought i was good
you know but
i didn't know if they were playing games
with me or what but i went over on the
wall i was like [ __ ] i don't know if i'm
gonna make it
that uh that guy that failed me who's a
great guy
but when he he's same thing he had me
down there i was down there
pool comp was 30 minutes when i went
through and i know they shortened it at
some point to 20 minutes but when i went
through was 30 minutes
and he just what he did was was he just
uh
he ripped my mask off and then he just
started doing like a bob
and he would bob down he would come down
he would just knock the regulator out of
my mouth
and then he'd go back up and i would
grab the regular i put it back in i'd
clear it and then he'd knock it out
again
and he did that for 19 minutes damn
and then and i just kept replacing it
and every one of those breaths was a
nightmare because you're trying to
go get them get the water out of there
swallow some of the water and then get a
breath and
then boom he'd knock it out again and
you can't defend yourself you can't
protect yourself and you can't panic
so i just kept doing it and then at 19
minutes he just comes down and gives me
the thumbs up
come to the surface and i come up and
i'm like i feel fine
and he goes he goes you don't look
comfortable down there you fail
and i was like okay so i guess that's
that roger that yeah what's a whammy nut
like they just tighten this complex not
oh it's like a multiple knots
okay so it's not like a specific like
methodology or is it just like a
generally speaking jam so during this
evolution called pool
competency also known as pool comp will
come
they want to make sure that you are
beyond fully
comfortable in the water you will not
pass this if you're not comfortable in
the water
zero percent chance so what they do is
they they
cause problems so you have these
old-school
scuba gear on like jacques cousteau
style stuff
these big hoses one hose goes in one
hose comes out and they're just like
rubber hoses
and they start taking these things and
they first they start off they knock off
your mask they rip off your fins
they pull your regulator out and then
they start pulling your regulator out
and then like undoing your
thing and eventually they pull it out
and put it behind you
pull your regulator behind you and tie
it in a knot you got to
take your gear off pull the rig over
your back
untie the knot start breathing again put
everything back on
in order following the procedures as
soon as you get it back on
boom they hit you again and so they keep
doing this and eventually
they give you what's called a whammy
knot which is a knot that you cannot get
out
you won't come out so now what you have
to do is ditch
your rig which means you have to take it
off you have to lay it on the bottom of
the pool
you have to take your weight belt off
and place it on top of the tank so they
don't float then you have to kiss your
regular or kiss your
manifold you kiss your manifold oh no
you request permission to go up they
give you permission you know you
give them a thumbs up they give you like
an okay thumbs up
then you kiss your manifold and then you
blow and go to the surface
and kiss your manifold you literally the
the part of the
scuba tank is called a manifold it's
where the regulator kind of comes out of
you kiss that like why
i don't get it because those are the
procedures oh that's
the deal okay like you got to follow
these directions kind of kiss your man
right did you have to kiss your
manifesto yeah so you kiss your manifold
and then you blow and go which means
you're not gonna give yourself uh
an air ambulance by the by the air
expanding your lungs
and you go to the surface you blow and
go to the surface when you get to the
surface you give a thumbs up and you say
i feel fine
and they either say you know good job
you passed or they say
you looked uncomfortable you failed
which for me they said you looked
uncomfortable if you failed
and then for steve they said you looked
uncomfortable you failed uh
i would say though one thing that's
different about me
was i did good on everything else so
when i failed pool comp i was like oh
god
like this is it i can't i'm i'm gonna
fail super sketched out
yeah not me that wasn't my first time
failing so so you like failed like
ditching down buddy breathe i was good
on the buddy
breathe uh ditching dawn and something
else i don't know what else i felt
like three things my buddy breathe
partner
was a freaking wrestler from iowa he was
a beast of a guy
he was a total freaking panic
in the water this dude would take the
freaking buddy breathe from me
because you're using one set of scuba
tanks he would take it and just breathe
off of it for like a long time
yeah and then he then i'd be like hey
you know like give him a single like hey
but i need that right now you know and
so he'd give it back to me and as soon
as i took one breath he'd be like you
know giving me the signal he needs more
but you but you passed the second time
yep passed it made it out
made it made in the third phase and then
third phase was uh
uneventful easier you know you're just
doing a lot of running swimming and
shooting so it was
it was that was a lot easier than second
phase
for me and running you were good
running good i had all my run times down
before i went into butt so i wasn't so
concerned about running i was just
worried about
kind of getting injured swimming what
about the open ocean swims good to go
no factor no failure did you you you
were honor man
yeah yeah so and you were firing the gut
yeah so the weight is impressive dude
yeah the way they worked it is i think
we voted the fire in the gut
before the honor man results came out
you know the class voted that for me and
i was like all right that's awesome and
then they're like hey
ward you got honor man too and i was
like all right check roger that
um well the reason i say that's
impressive is
the honor man is usually somebody that's
like it does really well in all the
events like
running swimming of course and the fire
in the gut is usually a guy that like
doesn't
it's a guy that had to kind of gruel
through it and gut through it to pass
like in my class it was jeff higgs who
had hypothermia
multiple times like five or six times
and he just
he he showed back up to buds even though
they kicked him out he showed up to
class in his dungarees and just kept
doing it
so he got fire and gut like of course
and then honor man was keith camille
who's a total stunt athlete
but for you to get both those that's
pretty freaking
yeah so how did you even get that i
don't know
i don't know man i don't know it didn't
feel like it you know were you one of
the leading guys
were you an e4 at this point so yeah i'd
made e4 off the ship before i went to
bud so i showed up the buzz and i was an
e4 already were you the class leading
petty officer
like a second class no we had a second
class in there and i think eventually we
had a you know he got
the the guy uh our original lpo he got
stress
fractures and um had real bad shin
splints so he got rolled out and another
guy came in
and he took over the class lbo stuff so
was it what was hell week like for you
i'll tell you what hell week wasn't it
wasn't as bad as i thought it was gonna
be
it sucks for everyone i had enough gas
in my tank i think i could have went
one more day but it you know it was
manageable yeah it was manageable
we just had a guy on who ended up in sf
but he went to buds
and he didn't make it through buds but
he said butts was really really hard
you know he was like that's he goes if
you're thinking you're going to go there
you're going to get what you asked for
yeah yeah yeah yeah for me hell week was
kind of cool because
i wasn't the best runner i wasn't the
best swimmer and so it was
like hard for me like i had to put out
super hard to pass those evolutions and
i had the fear of
failing yeah and and hell week
you there's no time limit on there's no
time limit on the evolutions
just keep going and i'm pretty good at
keeping going that's
that's a that's a good thing i'm good at
just keep going no matter what
i uh the one thing i remember about
helwick is you remember when we were
doing steel pier
that was one of the coldest points i'd
had in my life you know they were hosing
us off on that thing
and it felt like my damn hip flexors
were going to pop off we're doing
flutter kicks
and then they'd pop us in the ocean and
the ocean had been around 60 degrees but
the ocean was way warmer than it's
hot so you're in there and you're like
oh man this is great keep us in the
ocean for a little longer you know and
they pop you back up there
back and forth and man i could barely
walk when we got off of that damn
that damn pier so the pure evolution in
hell week was was horrible and then the
instructor is just
wrenching down on that rope when you're
carrying the boats
to and from child that [ __ ] sucked you
mean wrenching down on the rope
so that the thing is pulling down on
your head on your head yes
yeah i thought my little neck was gonna
snap off there were they jumping from
boat to boat when you were
we had instructors in our boat i don't
remember them jumping to another boat
but we were carrying them around
instructors were jumping from boat to
boat
damn and like i remember hearing my
freaking
neck bones just grinding yep and i was
like
this doesn't seem like it's good for me
but oh well
yeah so honor man and
firing the gut guy and of course you
check into team five and no one cares
about any of that no one cares you're
like hey new guy grab
go clean the [ __ ] or you're like damn i
thought i got away from these [ __ ] or
something
they're following me everywhere and you
checked into team five yep checked into
team five in august 1994 and then back
then you know we started to go through
sdt so they
pop you in a platoon and you start doing
your platoon work up but you also
gotta detach from your platoon and go
over and go through uh
sealed tactical training oh no kidding
so okay so but your your platoon work up
started
our platoon workup we it was almost we
were
a couple months before starting the
workup but we were broken off and
and going to stt and the platoon had
just started
some things when we had finished up and
you went to the group
stt didn't you no team
i think you know it was just the team
just to your team okay just our team
yep i thought they had already combined
because eventually they combined
yep where every guy went
directly to a group well not directly
but everyone went through stt together
for a while you know they still do now
but there was a time when they started i
thought they started around that time
so with you as just guys from team five
yep yep
was it run by team five it was wrong by
team five are trying to get yeah that's
the same thing that i did
and well did you have any idea what your
job was gonna be
no i got you know putting up a tune and
uh initially i was a
a dub a dub guy in there and i worked in
air
the problem i had with aw is i was
left-handed and uh we'd had one of our
guys in training and he's like hey man
you're
that dude's left-handed why do you guys
have them shooting at aw because you
don't have all the rounds
or the brass and um the link
yeah link are going out to the right
which is going right across your field
of fire and then you're in your face and
stuff so like hey put them on rear
security so
got on rear security for that first
platoon and then worked in there and
dabbled around and first lieutenant
and uh ordinance what kind of platoon
was it just a spec ops
spec offsplatoon yep yep so we were
deploying out to a little island out
there in the pacific
did you uh how was how was like your
platoon leadership
the first platoon was not was not good
so i got to see
hey what wrong looks like you know
and it was kind of funny like our uh was
a classic case of
you know our oic was was a good dude but
i think he was too smart for his own
good
and uh he he was a little more concerned
with
pt and being in good shape and he was a
phenomenal athlete like
one of them triathlete guys but it came
at the cost of
showing up to dive evolutions on time
she came at the cost of
being a good tactical leader down on the
ground which is what everyone's
hungry for um so i think he kind of lost
you know a lot of our guys respect and
he was kind of hard-headed you know
that classic uh i'm smart than everyone
else type thing
so it didn't go over good and it was
just a
it was weird you know it was weird and i
didn't realize how
you know trying to find of a good way to
wear this
it wasn't an ideal platoon right you
don't realize that until you get into
a really good video yeah for you you
didn't know anything different correct
so for you that's just the way a platoon
was
yep yep and the scary thing about that
is you get such a big impression made on
you by your first platoon
yeah that if you're not careful you can
think that
other platoons are jacked up because
they're not
like your first platoon yeah you know
you're so impressionable
yeah yeah so it was it was interesting
so the there was a huge difference
between my first platoon and third
platoon or
my the third platoon i did we were like
the best platoon of the team
and it felt good like the leadership was
dialed in they were balanced out
our platoon chief was squared away well
respected he was good tactically he was
good administratively like
that's the dude i want to be like you
know that wasn't your third platoon that
was my third platoon
you know my second platoon was was
better than my first still a lot of room
for
improvement you know and were you rear
security did you move up to point man or
something
yeah yeah i moved up to a point man at
some point i think my second platoon the
third platoon i was running point
running point you're tall for a point i
know how tall are you yeah
um six two yeah cause you have a dub
written all over you till they find out
you're left-handed
and what were you you know just to give
people a reminder this is the 90s
so we don't have a lot of assets nope we
don't have a lot of money
nope we don't have we're not really
doing any real missions
barely uh you know some guys like
gardner went to somalia
uh but that was a real rare occurrence
yeah so what we would do is
train get ready go on deployment kind of
party
um just kind of like what the what the
scene was
yeah i was kind of funny because when i
showed up to the team
gardner was already in their ear he had
a couple platoons on his belt
i'm on the damn quarter deck watch and
uh this dude has a long name
he's still in so i won't say his name
but he had a long name and i'm like
attention in the team five compound
someone so you know reports of the
quarterback and i butchered his name
what do you think's calling me on the
damn phone you know gardner and he was a
hard case man
hey uf the new guy say his name right
[ __ ] man that was a pretty good pretty
good gardener invitation
yeah it was and i was like damn i'm not
getting out of the compound tonight
without getting taped up and throwing in
a damn mill van you know yeah
so but so this was 90 yeah because
at that time actually yeah
at those years you were starting to get
a migration to team five
from like for instance from team one if
people wanted to leave team one if they
didn't like the stalog
yeah and so there's a whole like gang of
guys that went down to team five
i remember that to just get yeah to
have some freedom no fun one yeah
migrate down the street
[Music]
gardner was always at team five so he
was but he was just like why would i
want me more like why would i want to be
over there where there's a bunch of
rules that you have to follow
[Laughter]
yeah oh it was funny man well you could
always find gardner out when you're
doing uh working in the desert because
you just look for
some smoke look for fire look for fire
there's gardner he's lighting some [ __ ]
on fire
gardner guy so uh you do your third
platoon yeah
and then what what are you thinking what
do you think about your life at that
point so what year is it
so this is uh i finished my third
platoon in 99 and uh
so i was going through a divorce had a
kid and i was like hey i gotta hit the
reset button so
i talked to our master chief our cmc i
was like hey man he's like hey we want
to bring you in here and be the training
cell lpo and i was like hey man i got a
lot of baggage right now i need to
break contact here go reset so i got
orders
over to um our special boat team at the
headquarters element
and i got put in their training cell and
we were basically setting up operational
readiness
exercises just like we used to run yep
so
so you went just so everyone understands
you went from instead of being a teen
training cell which you're gonna be gone
all the time doing training trips you go
to a boat
training and then the ore training so
you're gonna be home a lot more
yes yep and so at that point i was ready
to go back to school so as soon as i got
there i was already enrolled back in
college on like a
a one-year i don't know what you'd call
it but you know they have the military
program so i was going to school
saturday and sunday to knock out all my
upper-level units from my bachelor's
degree
and then i was working on my lower level
units at the same time
so i did i winded up finishing up my
degree in about three years
and so i'm i'm there going into the
training we're home
away trips every now and then every now
and again and uh it was good man i had
good leadership in there these you know
the special warfare combatant craft
crewmen
them dudes are squared away and so i got
to learn a lot about the boats and that
playoff
or it helped me out later on because
you're really learning you know hey how
far can these things go load capacity
all those key tactical things that
matter when it comes into a mission
planning process for training or for a
mission
yeah and what's good is you start to
relate those to
helicopters aircraft and vehicles and so
it gives you a better sense
because as a young team guy i was really
lucky i was a co i was a communicator i
was a calm guy
so i was always involved in the planning
more than my peers
right the point man might plan the the
end you know the route
but like i was like okay here's what
we're gonna here's what we're gonna do
for communications
during the insert and then once we're on
target so i was more involved in
planning which was super lucky
and then i did args where i was working
with the marine corps
and working with the big navy so once
again what's the distance that this
helicopter can take us to insert us
what's the distance that we can get with
our boats what's the distance that our
ribs
once again the boats how far can they
take us what's their capacity
so i was very lucky that i got that
opportunity because once you realize
how to plan with assets yeah it's a big
it transfers to all different assets
makes you makes you smarter across the
board
yep yep so all that was good so
in uh while i was there at the boat at
the boat dead i was like
hey not much going on in the 90s i was
kind of like ready to punch out of the
military
and so i started uh putting in my
application for the chp
california highway patrol went through
all the interview process
all the testing got my letter of
acceptance and i was kind of just
on standby i was going to transition out
and then in august of that year in 2001
i made chief
i don't know how i made chief that you
know i wasn't expecting to put it on it
was like a total
shocker you know and then in september
2001 911 happened i was like all right
[ __ ] i'm staying in man we've been
waiting a long time to get in that
basement i've been training for whatever
it would have
been seven years yeah yeah so you know
from there i worked with
uh the cmc over team five to get back
there and he's like hey i got a platoon
chief slot open if you want him i was
like hell yeah
you rolled right into a platoon chief
slot yep
after september 11th yes so i went back
to the team i left like a few months
early t.a.d to go back to team five
until my orders could catch up
and then got over there and like i think
right around january
february timeframe we started forming up
our platoon getting ready for a 12-month
work upside though so you called the cmc
at team five
yep and said hey bro well
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't say i was
saying hey bro but
the other master chief i had with me at
the boat debt he was my
second platoon chief and he's like hey
i'm working with with jimmy over here at
team five you want to
they got a spot open you want i was like
hell yeah i want it dude my point is
like
hey man build some good relationships
with people yeah yeah
build some good relationships with
people because that
pays off you know and that means you how
do you build good relationships not by
kissing ass by working hard by doing a
good job that's how you build good
relationships
when i checked into team seven after
september 11th is actually like
whatever two years after september 11th
my
the the co there which
first of all the detailer who i was
friends with
sent me to the next deploying team so
when i left i had to go to college for a
semen animal program
when i left college i went to the next
deploying team yeah that's not luck bro
and then when i got to the team the
commanding officer who i had also worked
for in the past
yeah fired a platoon commander and put
me
in as a platoon commander whatever
three months before deployment damn
that's that's just
you know that's based on my past
performance and relationships for sure
but the relationships are built on the
fact that i worked hard
and was trustworthy to get the job done
yep
so you never plus you just never know
who you're going to be working with no
you know don't burn any bridges man
don't
don't burn any bridges yeah and just
going back to what you're saying there
that
your credibility in the teams is
everything your reputation
yeah you don't want to have a reputation
of being a you know a japanese
yeah cuckoo for cocoa puffs you don't
want to be that yeah
and your reputation is is a
i don't know what the word to describe
it it is a heavy thing
that sticks with you it's i should say
it's a sticky thing it's a sticky thing
and if you have good reputation it'll
stick with you if you have a bad
reputation
it'll stick with you it can take people
years to overturn
a bad reputation and interestingly it
can also take people years to ruin a
good reputation
yeah like a person with a good
reputation can make mistakes and people
like oh yeah don't worry about it's fred
you know fred's good to go
yeah or a person with a bad reputation
can make one little slip up and people
are like you got to be kidding me we
need to get rid of this guy
pull this right and get him out of here
yeah i like and i i hate to say that
because
right that's like that's like what
that's like political and all this stuff
but it's just the reality of the
situation and there's there's a reason
for that
because look human beings are going to
mess up but if you i guess the
difference is you have a good
a good person with a good reputation
they earn that reputation by consistent
good performance
yeah and eventually that reputation
stands on its own
and therefore if they make a mistake
which everyone's going to make mistakes
when they make a mistake when they make
a mistake which they will
people go oh you know like guess what
you know what
they've done they've done 100 good
things that's how they built that
reputation now here comes a bad one
all right we'll we'll carry on whereas
if you've done a bunch of bad things
and now you do something bad you're
you're good you don't have any leg to
stand on
yeah yep you're screwed so that
reputation thing
it's every it's everywhere it's
everywhere but man in the teams it's a
it's a big thing it's a big thing it's
damn near everything it's damn near
everything
it's damn near everything your rep uh
so you roll in now you're a platoon
committee a platoon chief at team five
yep
getting ready to deploy yes yep at what
point do you realize you guys are going
to iraq
we didn't know until probably january
so we're you know i'm there i get there
in october 2001
january february 2002 we start our 12
month long work-up cycle
and it's going through and it looks like
hey we're going into iraq
you know um we no one really understood
the scale of that thing
how big it would wind up being how many
years it would wind up being you know so
when they told us hey you're going over
we're like hell yeah man this is awesome
you know because you like everybody else
in the teams was worried that
there would be a three-month war and
you'd miss the whole thing
exactly exactly which is so hard to
explain to people
especially now that we've been at war
for almost 20 years straight
yeah it's hard to explain to people how
much it meant
to go to war when there was no war going
on
yeah it was everything like you were
just like man this is gonna be awesome
you know
and everyone's getting prepped you know
you know like i don't know what to
expect they everyone was thinking they
had chemical weapons
you know we were going through all kinds
of mop drills with our cbr gear and just
going through everything our eod guys
were getting everyone tuned up so we
were dialed in
um and you're looking at the freaking
mop uniforms
oh yeah and it's like got a elastic
draw string at the waist and like you're
thinking wait a second
this is supposed to keep me alive ain't
happening whatever
let's rock and roll did you ever think
that you ever take that charcoal
freaking
light laden suit and be like hey how
wait you're saying this thing's gonna
save me
it's got some elastic drawstring around
the ankles and that's supposed to
keep me good to go yeah that mop suit
didn't have a good reputation
dude for sure it was it was lacking i
don't know what
the u.s government paid for those mop
suits
and what level of security they provided
us but
i don't have a lot of confidence i
guarantee it was a lot and the gas masks
dude like one of the chances yep
but that's what we were getting told we
were gonna do and not one single guy
said no
because we i did one op
where we mopped up because we thought we
were hitting a target that had
allegedly some whatever chemical weapons
and you know what everyone did everyone
got jocked up everyone put those gas
masks on everyone put those stupid
freaking uniforms on
i'll tell you what we had quite a few
missions
when we got over to iraq where we were
going around with some of those three
letter agencies looking all over the
place
seeing what was around and everything we
saw was uh
was old it was like he'd been there left
you know
nothing new at all you know um as far as
cbr
cbr yeah [ __ ] like all the facilities
and everything was like
nothing's been here for a long ass time
so
so all right well let's so you get done
with your work up you find out you're
going to iraq
in january and you guys are going on
deployment in like april or something
yep yep april time frame so i team three
was already over there and just going
back to your relationships piece we had
a couple guys on the platoons that were
dialed in with some team three guys and
they started sharing information
you know back and forth hey here's
what's going on here's what to expect so
that gave us a really good idea on what
we needed to
prep for and so right around april time
frame we deploy over to
kuwait and we're staging in kuwait
waiting to go into iraq team three's
i think wrapping things up at that point
and we might already turned over with
them
um and we're actually in um kuwait for a
a handful of weeks there i want to say
right around three weeks and we actually
did our first stop out of kuwait into
iraq on 53s
yeah that was that sounded like a crazy
op it was good it was a good shakeout
nothing nothing happened but we planned
for 96 hours we went through
all of our helicopter rehearsals you
know and it was a big
op we loaded up those uh our dpvs dozen
patrol vehicles and we went in with a
big
package and we what was your mission to
go take down the the dam
get control get control of hadith it
wasn't hadith it was somewhere up north
korean okay so uh we went up there
and it was a long ass flight in there
and we're all jacked up on the cat now
you think you're going to get in the
[ __ ] you know
we're flying there we got our e r plan
laid out in case a helicopter gets shot
down we got our mop gear with us yeah
and we're roping down all 53s on the dam
with our cbr gear you look like you know
michelin snowman
were you massed up when you when you
fast roped we were not the the game plan
was secure the dam
get everything set up get everything
cleared and then they had some tunneling
systems in there because it was a dam
they wanted us to go inside the
tunneling system see if there's any you
know weapons of mass destruction or
chemical weapons in there so
the once we secured the dam which it
took a little while because you don't
really think about how big a dam is on
the inside there's
a lot of [ __ ] going on in there um is
this a one platoon op
this is so we had like a tune plus no we
had platoon plus we had our platoon
our mobility element and we also brought
in some
stv bubbas which was good they'd already
been there and they cleared a ton of
ships small you know little what do you
call the little boats out there
dows thousands they cleared a ton of
dials so these guys had already
had some reps under the belt so we were
excited to uh to get them on the off of
this
but yeah we went in there uneventful
cleared it checked the tunnels nothing
there
then we you know waited there a couple
days and we uh pulled out
but that that's a that's like a big
that's the big mish
that we were planning for in the 90s
like that type of thing yeah like hey
here it is
yeah you're gonna helo in this is the
big mish and plus
that was your first combat operation yes
yep it was a big deal it was like
it felt good to get that under our belt
in the mid and we
we um it was a good shake out for
planning because you know you're over
there going through the 96 hour planning
cycle
um a lot of good lessons learned first
time using 53s on a mission like that
um so it was good you know in in one of
the things i jacked up is
meeting another guy or medical guy who
squared away dude he stayed in the teams
for a while
but we roped down and we had our cbr
gear strapped on our
sides and so as we're coming down we got
that damn molly pack
you know you got to weave it in and out
of the the nylon
i didn't weave mine in and out like i
was supposed to so i went through a
couple but i left
like the bottom undone and i don't know
if i hit the wheel or the skin of the
aircraft but that thing
that damn thing came popping off of
course i had my mvgs in there
oh the helo you know and the uh the
backpack goes
over the side same thing with the other
cat that was with me
we think the world will wash you know
put it into the river and stuff
they never always talked about hey it's
not a big deal you can you get you know
write it off as a combat
it's a combat loss that's what everyone
was talking about you know like all
right yeah i guess it's not the big
deal combat last was like dude the
skipper was not happy
the combat loss write-off was not a
thing
well what's really not a thing is trying
to do a night clearance without nods
you got night vision we white lighted
everything then
okay so back then we're coming up on the
dam we're white lighting it and then
even the clearance on the inside
so you're lucky in that respect
what do you mean saying if you you see
you said you lost your nods right
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm saying you're
lucky that you didn't
yeah that you weren't you didn't need
him yeah yeah yeah
yes that is accurate because that would
have freaking you'd have just been blind
walking around yep waiting to
yeah walk into a wall yeah it was it was
just buddy along with somebody yeah it
was a good lesson learned from me
especially being a platoon chief did you
uh
that little molly weave how many molly
weaves did you make like two
i think i had about three in there i
think there was round five
and i just left out the last two and
snapped it in snapped her in
yep snapped her in get her done she's
good
not so good not a good situation and the
skipper was pissed
oh he was hot man i was on the mat with
him like he's
you know calling me to task on that one
yeah luckily like i said you had a good
reputation
like if you had a bad reputation at that
point that would have really sucked
yeah yeah would have really sucked
yep so that was your first big mish and
then what but that was out of kuwait
that was adequate yep and then what
happened then we moved up into
baghdad we had a little camp set up out
there we called it camp posey you know
we had a
i don't know if you know posey but a
good warrant officer vietnam dude yeah
yeah good
good stories man the best and we had
another guy we called him ranger and
uh those two dudes came in they helped
build out the camp you know we took a
ranger with us on uh
on quite a few missions good dude and
then we just started operating out of
posey into
baghdad yeah we're right there at the
baghdad international airport and what i
was impressed with
looking back what i am impressed at
looking back is
you guys were freaking super proactive
in getting
missions started like you guys were
super proactive in forming relationships
and and getting the intel that you
needed from various sources
and and starting to do a lot of
operations yeah we
set the foundation for you guys you guys
came in and did like
four times more than what we did but we
were definitely laying that foundation
and one of the things we had
our tash unit senior enlisted leader um
he was dialed in and he came from
damn neck and so he had a lot of good
relationships
and you know you know damn nick was over
there at that point and so he was tied
in with a lot of the three letter
agencies
which opened up the door with quite a
few missions
shared intelligence so that really
helped set that up that foundation for
us
and then from there we're starting to
get you know some good missions and hell
even if you're getting one mission
you're like all right we're good to go
you know because you think
we all think we're gonna be out of there
within six seven months like the whole
thing's shutting down yeah
um but obviously it didn't yeah so
what was your you guys got in some gun
fights too yeah what was it what was the
first one like what do you remember
our first shootout was kind of funny we
were dialing in our
standard operating procedures for a
shootout
um which we hadn't done like you know we
went through training training was good
but it was nowhere near the level that
you know we provided our guys once we
got over to trade it wasn't anywhere
near that
so we identified a few of the gaps we
had and we went we developed we brought
on the platoon we brought in
guys with experience and we developed
our standard operating procedure for
what we're going to do
inside a house if we get in a shootout
and it was basically suppress fire
cover crash maneuver using a cover and
move we're going to deploy some crashes
someone's going to be
suppressing fire while all that's
happening so on this particular mission
we went in and uh
the house the guy marked for us was the
wrong house we didn't know that we want
imagery everything looked dialed in
tight and they
mark it it looks good we go in breached
the door so we gone explosive so now the
neighborhood's starting to wake up we
clear the house i kept everything on the
clock we cleared the you know
two-story house in under two minutes and
we get the call on the net hey reset
the the actual target house is down the
street so we
reset reconsolidate you know one's on
the left twos on the right
gear check you know sensitive equipment
check everyone's good
come back out of the house grab our wood
ladders patrol back down the road
and the right house is marked and we go
up there and it was the right house it
had a double security screen door we go
explosive on it we got a
failed breach so now it's turning into a
big construction project
guys are up with not to mention just so
everybody knows like
after you hit the first house everybody
in a two mile square radius knows what's
happening and if you're in that
neighborhood you know exactly what's
happening
so if you're a bad guy in that
neighborhood you
are now alert and ready to be attacked
and you're prepping yep exactly so
now we got a fail breach we're on the
outside of the structure
the preachers are working through
getting through that heavy security
screen door
we're kind of raking windows we're
deploying crashes in there to keep
people away from the front door we
finally get entry
clear the first floor everything's good
we're dialed in and back then we always
pressed into our guys hey
you make the call if you stack on the
stairs you're the number two guy
you got three or four more guys behind
you make the call and go up the stairs
we don't want to just
have this lag period where you're
waiting for me or the oic to make a
decision tell you what to do
decentralized command
so the guys stack on the stairs i'm
right there i just came out of the the
kitchen area they start moving up the
stairs and there's
a young kid upstairs with an ak-47 so
he's like 10 feet away and he's just
full auto and our guys are on the stairs
they're trying to return
fire but the volley's just all around
our dudes man
um i'm yelling at the guys get back down
here they come back down the stairs
and then we go through our shootout
procedures which which pay dividends
they work
we couldn't shoot get at the guy because
the guy's on the second deck and now
we're down below him
so there's no way to get the direct fire
so our guys are exposing themselves a
little bit trying to get an angle here
guys are deploying crashes we deployed
about five six crashes
there's no more gunfire we're like all
right check um
we're going up so you know we go up the
stairs the kid had actually dropped his
gun we clear the
uh the second deck there's frickin smoke
everywhere so it was just
i mean we're gagging there's so much
smoke in the house
go up there the guy's not there we're
like where the hell did this guy go and
um our guys go out on the
on the on the deck patio and they're
clearing and now we're looking really
hard like where is this guy
and the kid is a young kid hiding behind
curtains and you know the guy's there
and then
boom our guys muzzle strike the guy get
him into the center of the room
we cuff him up and that was that so
uh anyone get hit by him by the bad guy
you know or our guy heading up the
stairs first the first guy up he had a
grazer over his mvgs
um it actually hit his his mount um but
he he didn't get hit
it was like it was a total pulp fiction
pulp fiction scenario
yeah like he had angels on his because
that could have been a bad night we
gotta have two three guys hitting that
one volley and no one got hit we
we were extremely lucky how many how
many rounds do you think the guy shot
one mag or two mags
did he get a reload no no he didn't get
a reload i think he got a full mag off
somewhere in between 25 and 30 rounds
damn dude yeah from 10 feet yeah yep
close it's close i mean i don't know how
he he probably missed because he was on
full auto you know all those things
yeah you're just bouncing all around
when you go on full auto
um in the dude you know the guy was just
a total douche douchebag that shot at us
to him he's like i love george bush i
love coca-cola and they're like you
just shut up man so yeah we cuffed them
up and that was that was emotional when
you're getting
shot at that close and you're dealing
with a bad dude that just tried to kill
you
you know those uh emotions get jacked up
pretty high
um we had some good teammates there i
mean i was i wanted to kill the dude
um but you we can't do that you know as
much as you want to
you're gonna it's not gonna be good but
we got them cuffed up took them over
to our uh detention facility and you
know the guys did good that night and
they did good because of
the training the talk throughs that we
did going through the checklist going
through
multiple rehearsals every time these
missions came up
all that panned out all that
worked in our favor for that one event
for that one shootout that all worked
for us
you know having uh having contingency
plans
which is that what you guys had yeah and
it's what you know we have all kinds of
contingency plans i mean every i
ad every immediate action drill that we
do is a contingency plan like oh if we
get shot at from over there so we're
gonna do a good shot from over there so
we're gonna do
so having those contingency plans it
just makes it so that you don't really
have to think decentralized command just
works
everyone knows what to do they know what
the objective is they make it happen and
so
you can make very little call very very
you can give
very little direction and things still
will proceed the way they're supposed to
yeah what about um
what about your next what about your
next gun fight so
our next one i think was our uh our
helicopter so we'd gone in after this
guy and he
um he shot an rpg and killed an army guy
and so we were going in after him and so
we came
and we did quite a bit of helo work that
deployment so we came in with our
helicopters and our game plan was to
you know land on the x assault the
building and get
grab the guy and go and he was out in
this uh i think he was actually out
in fallujah ramadi so there were some
palm groves out there
so on insertion we come in and and the
helicopters
went to the wrong house you know in our
mvgs back then they're kind of
they're not good so we could see how
that so we we sat down and we're like
this is not
the right house get back up they get
back up do one orbit come back in to the
right house
land us we dump off clear the building
everything's unavailable we get the bad
guy
now as we're going through all the uh
sensitive site exploitation we're trying
to grab as much as we can on this guy
you know we get a report as we're
breaking out that hey there's two or
three armed guys
coming your way in through this palm
grove so the helicopters were
a ways out but we had a gunship overhead
and so we set up a quick hasty perimeter
little foot shook and we're going to
wait to see if these guys came into us
well they never came into us they sent
something was wrong and they bagged out
so we get set up in the palm grove where
we're calling in
the helicopters at this point to come
pick us up
and as we're setting up the perimeter
you know someone calls out over the
radio hey man there's a tracer fire that
just went by
and no one else has seen it there's one
dude paying attention in his field of
fire sees one round
come in and so he calls it out so we
kind of go on hyper alert here
we're waiting we're watching and as the
helos are coming in this dude
they were probably like 300 yards from
us they start opening up with triple a
fire
over our lz now the only thing
protecting us at that time is we had a
palm grove
and the lz's here and the house is
somewhere over here so this tracer fire
is coming over the palm grove
and the the issue we had is like um
communicating this back up the chain we
had our tashkent commander on the ground
with us on this one
and some people just didn't see this
[ __ ] some people didn't see the tracer
fire coming
and i picked it up pretty damn quick
once the guy called it out you're like
holy [ __ ] that's a good volley of fire
we're gonna get a helicopter shot down
if we're not careful here
so anyways the helicopter comes in picks
up the package grabs our headquarters on
it they bounce out
and then we just go over to our
secondary lz which was you know pretty
easy
but uh it was very uncomfortable knowing
that you got triple a fire coming over
the top of you
you know when these helos get shut down
that's going to be a long night
especially out here in this rural area
we didn't have any backup
and then what was your op tempo like
it wasn't bad it wasn't like we were
going out dinging targets every night
but we would
uh we got a point there where we were
going out at least
twice a week i'd say once or twice a
week yeah more like twice a week but in
between that
we were doing other stuff like you're
doing mobility stuff you're going to do
a little bit of sniper stuff here and
there
um which which was which was good and
then just going back on decentralized
command you know the
the other cqc or close quarter combat
shootout we had you know our guys were
going up
to this uh house and man there's
freaking
telephone wires everywhere man and you
know how that is you're like there's no
rhyme or reason how do you guys live
with this just wires
everywhere you know and we got to hop
over this damn gate
yeah you know to get to this house so
literally like 30 or 40 wires
yeah like you could be just total mayhem
wires yep and we
we planned for we actually picked it up
on the imagery we're going through our
rehearsals and we're like hey there's
wires everywhere as you're coming over
at this spot right here be careful don't
get your nods hit on them don't you know
we got to be quiet so we start going up
and over we get the entry team
over and actually we had our full squad
into the courtyard because the distance
from the gate
to the actual house was a lot it was a
big house so we needed assaulters up
front
so we get up front in the uh you know
the entry teams
going through you know our breachers
going through laying the charge on the
door going through all the procedures
and the next scenario he gets is
bang bang bang doors rounds are coming
through the door
and so you know our breacher we borrowed
him from another platoon he was dialed
in good dude
um you and leif know him but so he's
he's laying the charge
and he's using his cover right if he's
in the center of the door the dude's
getting shot
with the 45 cow pistol but he's off to
the side using his covers like he's
supposed to sets the charge
our guys our other guys holding security
they go through our standard operating
procedures they're awake in the windows
they're shooting in through the window
to get the person away from it
and they're dumping crashes in to keep
the person away kick them out away from
the doorway
so boom we blow it of course there's a
propane tank there so the whole damn
doorway catches on fire so now we can't
you know we got a failed breach air we
can't get in there the door is open but
there's just this massive propane fire
going on
so we got to go to our secondary door
and get over the secondary door and
these
these dudes got a damn drop bar on there
so we i mean it took us forever to get
in it was a [ __ ] show
we get entry into the into the doorway
and there's like a family of eight
people sleeping in there and they're
like they're still
sleeping like how is it possible we just
blew in your door
there's gunshots going on and you are
you all are still like
physically sleeping like zombies you
know so anyways we got in there clear
the building
that sounds so unbelievable if you
haven't been to iraq before
like you can't explain things like that
yeah
you can't you can't explain things like
that no to get an explosive breach a
failed breach
shotguns going off of fire and the team
this freaking family just racked out
yep they're rocked out yeah they were
zombies man would did you ever catch the
guy that was shooting through the door
yeah it was uh it was actually the i
think it was uh one of the guy's wife
shooting through there and she's like
hey i thought you
thought you were looters you're like
coming in to rob our house we're like
yeah no we're not
looters you know but um anyways we got
that
situation all squared away that's a
rough that
well when i say that's rough one that's
the kind of mission where things can go
really sideways like if you start
fragging that room
oh man which you could easily do
yeah to say him look we just got shot at
i'm throwing some frag grenades into
this room and actually you know you got
a family
family that are getting blown apart by
frag grenades because the woman was
trying to defend her house from looters
which again may sound like a crazy story
and it could also be the absolute 100
truth
i don't know i'm not gonna try and you
know replay the situation that you lived
through but yeah
that could be legit yeah and you have no
idea
when you're out there and that'd have
been that would have been horrible yeah
it's been a freaking nightmare yeah
yeah well any other big missions that uh
that you guys did didn't you guys do
like some
some like essay 7 recovery or something
yeah yeah yeah so we
i forgot about that one so we're out we
went out there you know working with
some
other intel people out there and they're
like hey we're going after some of this
sensitive stuff here we you know anyways
so we went and hit this farmhouse we got
good air coverage overhead of us
no one's there the place is a ghost town
we start going through our sensitive
site exploitation
and man it was like a gold mine you know
the the perimeter around it was just
this big huge
cache and so we found a truckload of
you know uh sa-7 and sa-14 missiles
a ton of rpgs uh rock propel grenades
and launchers and so things started
getting
a little spicy around there so we're
calling a little bit of a fire support
and we actually had to turn that over to
an army unit who came in the next day
during daylight and they started going
through the field and there was like
i mean it was like radios it was like
enough [ __ ] to outfit a damn army
you know um so that was a that was a
good op nothing happened but we found a
lot of stuff so
you know you leave there feeling pretty
good about it and that
so that's a good that was a freaking
great deployment for you guys especially
in like
whatever 2003 that that deployment was
pretty freaking epic oh man we left
there and we're like we're the man
yeah we're never coming back here again
yeah because no one ever
no one ever thought you'd be back there
again no no no it was good and so the
one thing
we did that was really good with our
platoon
that we learned from the team three guys
when we relieved them is we shared
information you know i was back with
you know your old your brother there
team one
communicating everything i had back to
him hey here's what we're doing here's
what worked here was
here's what didn't work here's some
things to think about with mobility
and you just try to share as much
information as possible you know yeah
that way the next guy's coming in they
know what to expect and they can adjust
training
come in at a high level ready to to rock
and roll i know when you guys came in
you guys did
i don't know four times four or five
times the amount of missions we did for
that development
yeah well you get you guys were pushing
a lot of information back to us i know
you guys were feeding my platoon chief
and my platoon chief was already like a
mobility kind of
a mobility dude and so he was just amped
bro
we were doing freaking uh freaking tire
change drills like
nascar like a pit crew i mean it was
just like it was on
but here's the funny thing we were we
were on an ore
prior to that deployment so like maybe
three months before going on deployment
we were on an
or we we did our ore shipboard
and we went and we were doing
hydrographic reconnaissance of red beach
up at camp pendleton with lead line and
slate dude
like it was the world hadn't caught up
yeah
right the world hadn't caught up yet and
thank god
you know like after that we were we we
found some humvees we borrowed humvees
from like the seabees or something
and started running up running you know
training ops
down at like the old ntc
the old naval training center where they
had a bunch of old buildings that were
all
dilapidated but we started running
little ops in there with our
you know and our task unit commander had
actually been
in iraq on the push-up so he had some
experience our tasking to sca
had also been in iraq on the push-ups so
he had some experience
um which was awesome and they're both
great guys
so we were we and we were just going off
of the reports of how you guys were
doing stuff
and we were just like okay this is what
they're doing cool this is what we're
going to do this is what they did this
is how they regular vehicles okay this
is how we're going to rig our vehicles
so that's kind of what we did
and then i know you and i did a turnover
and it wasn't we we did it like bahrain
right
yeah bahrain that's where i was at we
had a platoon left up there and
our mobility element was left up there
yeah and we came back a few weeks early
out of bahrain just because there was
enough room to
bring everyone in so yeah so we sat down
did an awesome turnover with you guys
with you and your oic yeah who's a
freaking great dude that was awesome
and i was kind of like i knew who you
were yeah
just from i guess being around but then
that was that was when i was like
that's when i first really remember
getting a working like
you know i might have seen you at mcp's
or something
you know but the first time i ever
actually got a working
i think that was the first time i ever
did some kind of working uh i think it
was the first time i crossed paths with
you
yeah yeah you always hear the name out
there i mean i was roommates with taco
and taco had nightmare stories with you
and
chris he's like those guys man they need
to quit beating us up
we were
we had the gang mentality for sure for
sure um
so what'd you do when you got home from
that deployment so got back off that
deployment and uh there was another
platoon chief slot open
so that seems he was like hey man you
the guy that was going to come doesn't
look like he's going to come you want to
do another one i was like hell yeah i do
so then you know
started form up another platoon got a
bunch of new guys in new orc and
start another 12-month work-up cycle
dang
that's you got freaking two platoon
chief slots yep yep
it was awesome man that's the best job
in the world the task unit
spot is is good yeah the tune chiefs saw
it's a lot oh yeah platoon chief i mean
i always say like
e5 in a platoon i was just talking to
some guys the other night that were
e-files from studios like hey
you're good man e5 and platoon is an
awesome place to be and it is
it is it's an awesome place to be and
hopefully you reach a point where you go
i can take care of those awesome guys
yep and that's when you go okay i'm
going to be an lpo or i'm going to be a
platoon chief or i'm going to be a you
know if you go the officer route you can
try and go that officer out but
at some point you realize the best thing
i can do as a
to be a good e5 to take care of the
other ve5s means i got to get promoted i
got to take care of them
and the best way i can do that is to
increase my rank a little bit yeah so i
have a little bit more sway
yep we don't have to do dumb [ __ ] yep
you know i'm complaining about my boss
you know you can only complain so much
before you got to actually do something
about it yeah
absolutely and it's rare that someone
gets to do
platoon chiefs back to back like that i
mean no it's rare that a guy even gets
to do two platoon chiefs slots
that's freaking rare yeah we're getting
better at it now
that's one of the things that i know
what the headquarters level they're
really looking at you know before the
our um our rating really took control
over hey you can only do one you got to
move out another guy's got to move in
and they started looking at that because
you know we had we were losing quite a
few tactical leaders
like their guys are getting fired why
are they getting fired hey they need
more seasoning
yeah hey let's grab let's keep two three
guys that are doing really good
to keep that uh god what's the word i'm
looking for continuity
continuity at the team and these are
dialed in people you know you can count
on them and uh
move it forward so we've gotten better
with uh with that over the last 10 years
so those guys it's common now for your
top two or three guys
to stay of the team even if they pick up
senior chief they're gonna stay in that
platoon chief
yeah that's awesome yep that's awesome
and so then
you do another work up you must have
been freaking dialed now you're doing a
second platoon chief workup the second
platoon chief was way easier than the
first hell yeah
the first one so i didn't do a platoon
lpo so i was sucking on a fire hose
okay you know what i'm saying oh yeah
yeah so
you know setting up the platoon there's
just if you had never worked in training
either
nope not a team see i'll tell you man
my whole you know that's probably
you know my first three platoons the
leadership strategy tactics we were
talking about my first three platoons i
learned these certain things right
and i wrote about it leadership strategy
and tactics
but where that was like where all these
seeds got planted
yeah but i'll tell you what you want to
know where the fertilizer and the water
came from on those seeds
it was working in training cell at seal
team one where i was
a single enlisted e5
and you know what trip i went on every
freaking trip there was
i taught everything i would volunteer
for every course i'd
you know we would go teach land warfare
then i teach diving then i teach cqc i
just do
and i was the main instructor on any of
them yeah i was just a guy that was out
there like i'll go on that trip oh i'll
go on that trip
and that's where those little seeds
started to
come to fruition and the biggest thing
was when you're instructing
and you know this now that we worked in
land warfare when you're running when
you're watching i ads or you're
teaching i ads you are de facto detached
so you're watching and you can see
and you realize how easy it is when
you're detached and when you realize how
easy it is when you're detached and
you're going to wait a second
if i'm in there i just need to take a
step back and see what the hell is going
on and i can make a good call
so that is where i learned
so much so for you have to not done that
definitely had to make your first
platoon chief go
around a little rough it was hard i got
lucky like the our sister platoon
that platoon chief was dialed in he'd
done all those things he was on his like
seventh platoon
i was doing my fourth at the time
and so i leaned on him i'd ask him a
hundred million questions on things and
he always gave me good uh good guidance
man
yeah daniel good dude you know oh yeah
yeah and so then you get done with that
one
yep and now you're now you're going
through it again and now you're kind of
like i'm like this is easy
you're dealing with the same issues i
got all my standard operating procedures
in place
so for every block of training we're
doing plus you're a freaking combat vet
i'm a combat you're kind of the man i'm
ready to get after it yeah
so it was way easier man way easier you
know you're always going to have those
same personnel issues and now you know
how to deal with them
you know what right looks like yeah
and then what was that um then you were
going back to iraq again
yep so we wound up back over you know
you guys came in in late
september 2003 we went back in september
and the place was just a disaster
roadside bombs all over the place
you know the drill four fighters all
over the place it was a [ __ ] show
yeah that that was the the end of my
first deployment was when we went and
got yakube which was solder's guy and
that set the whole freaking thing into a
just a
total mayhem and we saw that we saw the
like it was it was a radical change
yeah because before that
like in what would be in march
of 2004 it was kind of like okay we'll
go do a mission
in april we were you could look out
and you'd see smoke and fire vehicles
burning and like it was
totally it was a very different scenario
yeah in that one month period
in april of 2004 and um
it just got worse from there yeah and
then by the time you guys showed up
it was yeah it was a disaster i remember
and we were doing the psd mission so we
weren't doing our typical
direct action but we got in there and in
my platoon we got split up so we're
in squads now supporting other platoons
because you need x number of people to
protect these guys
um and one of the good things that the
headquarters element did is
they rotated guys out for a sniper
mission so if you're sniper qualified
you
come on in and so we covered down within
our psd elements
and guys go out and do sniper stuff so i
was lucky i got to
get out there on haifa street a couple
times were you a sniper
yeah yeah sniper yes i went through and
uh i went through sniper
school in 98 and that was back when it
was out of cold lane and stuff and when
i got back off of
that deployment 99 i want to work for uh
mark he was running the
sniper core so i did a couple of
instructor you know uh
courses with him so it was good and that
helped me out for
you know the 2003 deployment 2004 the
2006 department you know
but i remember getting out on haifa
street it was the first time we're out
and we did sniper work in 2003 but there
wasn't nothing going on everything was
under control and i remember going out
there we're supporting an army unit
they're doing a clearance
so we come in dump out of the bradley
set up in the in the buildings
we got all our sectors covered and like
there's this
mood in an apartment building with an
rpg
launching rpgs at apaches that are in
the area
and like you know the deal like you
don't shoot a rocket from
a room that's not good good practice
right you're going to jack yourself up
he's just in there getting after don't
don't and like so the package is coming
and they're just like go
go go and they just take the dude out
and you're like holy [ __ ] man this place
is
not good totally different and then you
come out for extract the brads are
coming in to pull us out and like
there's
rounds coming in at you we didn't deal
with that in 2003 2003
we had the upper hand you know you're
operating at night time but we had
the upper hand with what we were doing
um so it's just
it was different and at that same time
in 2004 you had phantom fury out there
and
fallujah going off you know you had good
dudes supporting that and that was just
i remember looking up on the uh the jock
screen
and the marines are going through and
doing a clearance at nighttime and
there's like grenades getting chucked
out and the marines are just
going in and getting after it i mean
they're carrying like 25 mags in there
and going building by building and like
god bless the marine corps man these
dudes are like
badasses and we all wanted to be there
like hey switch with us man come
do the psd thing we want to be out there
doing what you're doing
um but so anyway so you know phantom
fury just died down like hey we want to
send a
a sniper element up to samara and so
like
leif got chosen to be oic and i was like
hey they
selected me to come in there with life i
was like cool put our 10-man 11-man team
together
went up to smart and we thought we were
going to get after it you know it was go
time
it was go time we were going to get some
and it was uneventful man nothing
happened we set up damn there we were
out in the streets every damn day
setting up man
and it was just you know that the guys
were going after their real cage it was
like civilians
like you don't know what your enemy
looked like they'd come in and set an
ied you didn't know they said it and
then they'd be out of there
how many how much did you spend how much
time did you spend on haifa street
not much i'd say i probably got out
there about six or seven times total for
that and i was only in iraq for 90 days
during that time period and then you
rotated out to the pacific
yep yep over to pi yep guam and pi
and the psd was a look it was a hard
mission and everything
but relatively uneventful because that's
what it was
so uh at that time seals were providing
security for the top
seven something like that uh authorities
in iraq and you know in charge of
keeping him safe
and he did an awesome job yeah but that
in doing an awesome job meant it wasn't
action thankfully yeah because the
action probably would have been a giant
2000 palm
v bid that would have killed everybody
or some something crazy like that
yeah in in 2004 that was the first time
we i really started seeing
the you know uh you know the truck bombs
the car bombs they're building
and i mean they built them you know this
they they put so much explosives in them
that the damn
springs and shocks would break on them
you know they'd be trying to get on base
and they're like
jacked up you know yeah not good so
but that but that wrapped up another
deployment for you yep
and and then so then what then what'd
you do
so then stayed at team five i made uh
senior chief
in 2005 picked up a potential you're
making up for going to the fleet ud
yeah i mean you're making rank quick oh
man yeah
were you making rank quick for on
average above average it seems like you
are
yeah so i would say probably above
average up to
chief and then you know i got passed
over the first time for senior chief and
then
made it the second time rightfully so
you don't want guys to make rank too
fast you want guys to really understand
what they're doing and why they're doing
it which takes time it takes a lot of
reading
takes repetitions and i think when i put
on chief i didn't i was undergunned
you know with my my training and my
experience
so it was good that i got passed over my
first time for senior chief
you know so anyway so i made senior
chief in 2005
and then picked up a task unit and you
know from there we started
working up to relieve you guys when did
you guys know that you were gonna
relieve us
i would say right around march april
time frame of 2006 right when you're
so we got there yep right around that
same time yep yep they're like
you guys are gonna come in behind these
guys and replace them at what point did
you guys start tracking like what was
happening
you guys started getting hot and heavy
in what may june time frame
yeah in april time april time yeah like
as soon as we got out there it was
getting crazy
it was right around then in like we
all of us were just kind of thinking hey
it's going to be like a fallujah style
clearance and fallujah went pretty quick
yep it went pretty quick you know there
was a lot of you know
a lot of good work being done a lot of
people getting killed u.s soldiers
getting uh injured um
we thought it was going to be like that
we didn't know it was going to be what
it was
you know we hadn't gone up against uh
that type of uh enemy before
yeah well we thought it was going to be
a fallujah type thing too yeah and we
talked about this on
on the unraveling with daryl cooper
that we well that's what we got told
when we got there they're like hey you
guys are gonna we're gonna do fallujah
and we're like
thank you thank you this is going to be
because fallujah at that point was a
real
high water mark for for just awesome
crushing kinetic operations by the
marine corps and there was seals in
their support and they did a great job
so we were thinking okay like it's on
and it's going to be whatever it's going
to be two weeks or three weeks maybe a
fighting it will get cleared through the
city
but it ended up not going that way it
ended up being that
there's a smart move by the prime
minister
who was a shia to recognize that if if
the
shia army which basically was a shia
army went in there and did this type of
crushing kinetic sweep through ramadi
which was most which was sunni
it would have set up sunni versus shia
civil war and so he said we're not doing
that
you're gonna find another way to do it
and the other way to do it was
a counterinsurgency was going into the
neighborhoods
and trying to pervert preserve the
infrastructure and trying to keep the
civilian populace as safe as you can as
you do it
and yet at the same time do battle with
these
insurgents so that's what that's what we
ended up doing
and i i always wonder what it was like
for you guys once we started taking a
lot of casualties and
once we started losing guys you guys
must have been like
um
a little a little uh nervous about
coming oh
hell yeah yeah absolutely man no no one
had been through
you know that amount of uh combat like
for us at that point
like heavy combat you know we had uh
our group commodore he was out there
with us doing our
you know uh ore what do they call the
final battle problem
and he's like hey man you guys are going
to ramadi stand by there's
a lot going on there and it was like i
mean a lot going on there
and uh and i think things really hit
home for us um
like i remember kelly coming back when
he was shot and like you look at these
things you're like okay
that's manageable like hey he's shot
he's coming in through
it looks like he's gonna be okay and
then
[ __ ] really hit the fan for us when mark
was killed we're like holy [ __ ] this is
we're going into something
that we like you know we hadn't been in
before
um so we had like we dialed in our
training you guys were giving us
information
telling us everything you're doing
what's working what's not working
we had some hard conversations with our
operators hey man like
someone's gonna get wounded someone
might get killed like we there's some of
these things we can't control what we
can do is
our rehearsals train to this make good
decisions on the battlefield to reduce
our casualty levels
but we're gonna be shot at someone's
gonna get hit that's coming and at the
end of the day it's gonna be us standing
here that's gonna kind of get us out of
this [ __ ]
so we gotta we gotta run a tight game we
gotta be tight with what we're doing
um and the guys understood that you know
guys understood that
um but it's different when you get on
the ground and you got
a lot of rounds coming at you you know
yeah you know it's i i try to i'm trying
to think of a way to explain the
difference
that in my mind that you got like
it seems like but prior to that point
most of the times
when guys would go out even when guys
would go out and get wounded or guys
would go out
and no one had been killed in iraq yet
but even in afghanistan it was like
it was a mission right it was like a
mission a
an isolated mission where something had
happened
and then once that isolated mission is
over
it's like you reset the clock and now
okay
we're in a different it's a different
mission and so it's almost like like you
do get to reset the clock
yeah but in ramadi it was like you were
in the same game and the clock was
freaking ticking the whole time
yeah and and so you guys knew that you
were just going to come in and get in
the game
and it wasn't going to be one mission
and it wasn't going to be three missions
it was going to be
mission after mission after mission
after mission after mission and it was
going to be
as many days as you were there
and um yeah i remember you guys showing
up and i remember
actually briefing your task unit and
literally saying you guys are gonna
you guys are gonna take casualties which
is the which was the
it was a thing i was thinking to myself
do i say that
is that a bad attitude is that a
negative attitude is that a
self-fulfilling prophecy or is that just
the [ __ ] truth about what's going on
yeah and i would rather have you guys
thinking okay
this is the truth and if we can avoid it
great but we have to be ready and we
need to do everything we can but we got
to be ready for it yep
yep i remember you guys were telling us
man we had
we had our go bags ready so if someone
gets injured or our standard operating
procedure in place with who's going with
the guy that's injured
all of our passports ids everything
we're in the bag someone gets injured
boom they're getting all the helo with
the injured guy
they're pushing out you know at least
getting them over to germany
um so we were definitely in the right
mindset
um you know when our first op out there
you guys helped set that up out there at
firecracker
oh yeah and that was that was a good one
with the marine corps we set you guys up
at firecracker for your
first [ __ ] yeah you're like hey
you guys are going around racetrack and
we'll just call this uh we'll call this
operation
firecracker because there's gonna be
some [ __ ] going down up there god
yeah it was it was it was a good first
shakeout
you know in the marine corps up there
you know the colonel that was running
the marine corps i forget his name
but he's just a good outstanding good
leader
just good like good dude man um so we
set that up and it
you know there's a you know our guys our
snipers killed a few guys on that one
which was good
um you know and they come just remember
there's a humvee out in the street and
he's
pulling security down from us and the
dude starts you know gets lit up with an
rpg
and like the marines are dumping out of
it and they're doing covered move drills
getting back and they're taking small
arms firing we're in a position where we
can't
that you know the enemies in dead speech
we can't even do anything to support
them
um they come back and there was a couple
like smaller mortars that came
in that day not you know didn't hit our
building but they were out in front of
us here it wasn't too bad they were
small
um but it was a good it was a good
shakeout for us like a little confidence
builder whacked a couple bad guys
no one got injured these are all good
things
and then you guys start started rolling
then we started rolling
and uh our first i was on that mission
the next mission we did i was not on
and our guys went up down the street i
think from falcon
and they're setting up overwatch
positions and you know
they're i think they're in the morning
time and grenades come in
you know i think they had one or two
grenades come in they yell grenades the
guys are diving down the stairs and
we had two guys get fragged from those
um and from that point it was like all
right
you know we knew we were getting into
but then it's like now it's real
you know now our guys are getting
injured we knew we're gonna get wounded
now you got two guys wounded with frags
and their injuries weren't bad enough
they had to get medevaced out so they
stayed
they stayed with us you know it took
them about three weeks to to heal up and
there they were okay that was like your
second
op yep yep that was like our second one
yeah yeah and then uh you know
throughout that thing there
you know one of the things i realized
this is further down the road but we did
this
this river open we're going to set
support setting up a combat outpost
and we're using the marine riverine yeah
yeah
unit and those guys were awesome yeah
they're awesome i think how funny that
is like hey the navy's supposed to
deliver the marines
yeah now the marines are delivering us
and they were good dudes man they were
down there they were awesome they were
squared away so they take us down river
and we had all of our deconfliction up
hey here's when we hit this
point in the water call up to the
security army security checkpoint up
ahead
make sure everything's dialed in went
through all the procedures and there was
obviously a disconnect so we get
close to where we're going and we can
see the security position
off to the right and it's on a two-story
building and we get that
we're like that's not good that's a
round coming over our head from the
security position
and then we're like hey let your strobes
do your [ __ ] and then the boat starts
speeding up a little bit to get us to
shore and like now we're all pissed
because we just got shot at
and then we get the you know like
freaking tracers are coming over us
we're like
[ __ ] get us to the shoreline man so
we get to the shoreline and we're
dumping out at that point it's a full-on
dude i just got chills just got chills
because because when you're taught start
talking about you're receiving fire from
friendlies it's
freaking horrible and then it's a
full-on no we're not shooting back yeah
but then it's full-on they think we're
moved
in boats coming down the river and it's
just cut cut got
we're dumping off in the tools and i'm
i'm freaking hot man so i'm
dumping in the side of the toolies and
we learn from you guys hey
deconflict that with your white star
cluster so i had old trusty right here
you know and as i'm going to the
shoreline i'm popping this thing out my
weapon's flying all over the place
and i'm yelling at the aoic i was like
hey freaking call back here and get this
[ __ ] deconflicted now
and i'm pissed i'm yelling at him i'm
yelling at him he's like what the heck
do you think i'm doing what the heck do
you think i'm doing i'm like
[ __ ] hurry up man and so we're
yelling back and forth i'm popping up
the white star cluster and of course as
soon as you get the white star cluster
up it
the [ __ ] stops yeah but i couldn't get
to that damn thing
fast enough by the time i got it i had
it out in probably like less than 30
seconds
dude 30 seconds a long time to be
receiving free fire from american
machine gunners
yeah we were all sucking mud man so it
was a good lesson learned one of the
things with ramadi is when you go into a
high stress
environment there's multiple units in
the area
the likelihood of you having a blue on
blue you just go up drastically you know
you
you've done a lot of podcasts with the
vietnam [ __ ] so when you're in those
type of environments
you've got to have your deconfliction
down you can't you can't do it enough
really yeah and you know another thing
i've been thinking about
is from a leadership perspective a thing
that i've been talking about all the
time is
is like if if you if you work for me
and i come to talk to you i gotta
understand what your perspective is like
i gotta understand that
so that i can like okay he's reacting
like this because of that and
and even more in depth than that i gotta
kind of know what your freaking story is
so i can't just know your perspective i
got to know what your story is
like oh this is steve he's he's been
here for 20 years
he's he's done a good job he also is
known for having a bad temper
he also has some trouble at home right
now so i got to know this stuff
yeah so that i can assess like okay what
approach am i going to take what reacts
am i going to get
well guess what when you're in a combat
situation
you better think about the perspective
of the people that you're
working with yeah because guess what you
take a kid that's
18 years old he's scared shitless he
doesn't
he he's freaking sick of being on this
post he's afraid he's gonna get killed
he's not being briefed by his seniors
he's tired
he's pissed off he's got an itchy
trigger finger
and what do you think this guy's gonna
do
yeah he's gonna shoot at you if you
don't make it clear what's happening
so it's important to remember that you
when you you have to understand other
people's perspective and understand what
their story is and then you need to
account for that
yeah somehow otherwise
bad things happen and like that's a
nightmare man like if those
those there's no protection on those
cirque boats i mean you're if that
if one one iteration of fire hit those
circles you'd have three four guys dead
wounded whatever
yeah maybe more yeah i mean you got 10
guys in a boat
damn it's a nightmare yeah yeah it
wasn't good and just talking about
perspective i know the army guys
there were a couple units there that you
know they'd been there for like
eight months i want to say like eight
months and then they get the call hey
you're gonna stay like
three more months oh yeah and them dudes
are wore out man i mean they're pulling
security out front they're taking round
rpg rounds they've lost two of their
friends through their friends for their
friends
they've seen vb ieds go in they've heard
rumors about boats
i mean yeah and look the army guys and
the marines that were there the most
professional badass dudes
ever ever but there's a lot of them
yeah and if you if you have look you can
have a platoon
of 40 guys and 39 of them can be the
most squared away guys you've ever met
and can understand everything and be
calm cool and collected but there's
gonna be one person in there
that's not yeah and and once one person
starts shooting
bro it's a real problem to get
it's a real problem if you think other
people aren't gonna start shooting as
well
that's that's what we literally get
trained to do
oh if there's a contact start shooting
help your buddy yeah
yeah not uh not good understandable
but uh not not a good situation we
definitely could have done a better job
on that
with us um yeah it wasn't good we were
lucky no one got hit on that one yeah
yeah we had one other blue on blue that
i know about i'm convinced there's
i'm convinced there's probably quite a
few blue on blues going on that you just
don't
you don't know um there was
because i was i was we'd talk about this
with the brigade commander all the time
there was one there was usually one blue
on blue
per day per day
but that that wouldn't get reported and
there was one blue on blue per week that
actually got reported yeah of like hey
we were taking fire from this unit at
this time
most of them was like hey fire shoes
fire
you know that's a friendly position like
that happened all the it happened once a
day
yeah once a day you know usually at
night but the the
most harrowing example of that was there
was a blue on blue between humvees
like one humvee at night saw another
humvee and started shooting at it
yeah and there wasn't no muge that had
humvees like at least the boat
the boats weren't super common to be in
the river even the marine corps boats
they weren't super common to be in the
river so if they rolled out someone goes
oh wait a second i don't know what this
is
this might be moose boats let's shoot
them but a humvee
like that's how itchy the trigger
fingers can get and you got to
understand people's perspective man we
were so freaking paranoid about that
stuff
yeah yeah it was uh it wasn't a good
feeling that's for sure
jeez and there's nothing you can't like
what are you gonna do
shoot back no like you can't do that no
yeah you've grabbed that damn white star
cluster
fired off boy damn yeah
we had one other blue on blue where we
were out there and we were down there by
grant
cop grant and uh we went to the unit
deconflicted everything and you know our
guys went out there and
we're getting set up on a rooftop and
like you're like
damn come on man yeah you know what
wasn't good but
um those high stress level areas
people are getting wounded and [ __ ]
people are going to see different things
it's out there it's real you got to be
careful yeah when life and i wrote
extreme ownership like
we didn't plan to write there's three
chapters in there that are just blue on
blue chapters
yeah out of 12 chapters yeah so a
quarter of the chapters are about blue
on blue
like that's we didn't think about that
but that's what the reality of the
situation was
those are some of the scariest cities
you know what's crazy is when we went
back to trade
and we incorporated our our laser gear
oh yeah
people found out how easy it is to have
blue on blue just to your point with
perspectives like we
drew that out and it was awesome to draw
that out in training
um but yeah
so anyway so after you know after those
handful ops
we had uh you know we had november 19th
and so this is
putting us you know right before
thanksgiving and
we had the whole task in it out and so
we had uh you know our cricketer guys
are up in the papa
suckers our our ari platoon is down
we're down past grant i think we're down
past ground that area
we're about eight blocks from those guys
half mile mile something like that
maybe juliet yeah juliet sector yeah
i don't remember all the sectors but man
we're out there and things are going
good in like eight o'clock in the
morning we're set up we got mutually
supporting
positions with our platoon they got
mutually supporting positions with their
platoon
things are good and i remember the first
thing i was like all right this is going
to be a [ __ ] show
in here you know we had a car going
around with the the
hazards on you know so they're signaling
in the area hey man
u.s troops are in there but they didn't
know where we're at we didn't have any
you know loopholes we didn't pound out
any any
any brick or use explosives so they had
a hard time figuring out where we were
throughout the whole day
but as we're sitting there things start
heating up you know hey there's mams
over
two streets over and uh they're all
consolidating one area they got weapons
and then you know hey
it's coming we're going to get we're
going to get in the mix here
and so like around 11 o'clock we started
calling in
for our our gimmelers on a guided
multiple launch rocket system
and and we started getting that ready
commensurating coordinates to to bring
in rockets
because it was different requirements
that wasn't coming from off the rails
from the air
so it was easier to get it approved and
so as we're doing that you know we get a
call over the radio you know that
you know our other unit from corrigadors
hit and we didn't know how bad they were
hit but you know
the aoic came over was like hey man
elliot said he's in bad he's in bad
shape and so is joe you know and we're
like oh [ __ ] man
you know they're taking them down to the
cash and [ __ ]
which wasn't good we're like everyone
just got a sick feeling to their stomach
you know
but we didn't know what it happened
until after we got back but we're like
[ __ ] is he gonna make it he's not gonna
make it but you know those guys were in
a position they started taking light
fire
and as they're taking light fire you
know they had rooftop jumpers in ramadi
they get as close as they could and they
dump grenades right on top of your
position so the first thing that
happened is
they had a grenade dumped on their
position and ellie gets sliced in the
damn
wrist pretty bad so you know they're
collapsing off down off the rooftop and
we had explosives up there so the guys
were clacking off explosives to
you know move the the rooftop jumpers
away from from their guys
so as they collapse down into
you know on the bottom floor
everything's still under control there's
a light bully of fire they're calling to
the other
the other sniper supporting element hey
we're hit we're going to call in an
extract as they're calling an extract
you know the the the iraqis come out and
our unit comes out to get in the
bradleys and you know they're hit with
some type of
white phosphorus explosive device and i
did a lot of analysis on
what that was a roadside bomb what was
it i can never determine what it was
but you know what killed i think three
iraqis wounded two
r2 guys our two seals were hit
critically injured
you know so now they're pulling everyone
back into the house
the bradleys are getting out of there
because it's just a total [ __ ] show
um the other units fighting their way
down the street to get in a position to
help these guys out by this
by this time um in long story short you
know everyone's in a bad position and
and elliott was such a uh is such a good
dude
he's sitting there telling dudes he's
cool calm and collect he's got [ __ ]
burning on him you know burning through
his camis and he's telling guys what to
do to how to patch him up and do all
this [ __ ] and he's jacked up
um you know and joe he had his legs kind
of blown backwards
on his lower extremities so it's a
complex situation you know outside still
heated up
injured guys on the inside dead guys our
own dead guys iraqi troops out on the
street
guys fighting their ways back down it's
like as bad as the situation
is as you can conjure up right
but you know they get things under
control they call in another quick
reactionary force they load these guys
up and you know that's when we get the
call over the radio that those guys have
been hit meanwhile over in our sector
things are starting to heat up and so
we're
spinning up aircraft we're trying to get
our gamblers in position to start
launching and you know our guys are out
there
you know laying down some a dub fire and
launching a few carl gustav rockets into
some positions down there by us but it
was just a
you know shitty day for us you know the
you know obviously the whole task unit
was hit
was hit hard on that um wasn't good um
yeah and i mean elliott is probably
one of the most severely wounded seals
from the iraq war yeah yeah he's i mean
he's
he's a freaking warrior yeah but he
he he took a heavy hit that day yeah
yeah and
you know an elliot's story you know that
guy never quit he never gave up on life
and um you know he's going through
physical therapy
and him and his physical therapist fall
in love
and elliot marries her they get married
they have kids
um which is just awesome you know i've
seen elliott a handful of times
over the years you know at bud's
graduations and stuff like that
um you know just sucks that [ __ ] i'm
doing man
yeah and leif was super good friends
with elliot and
you know obviously we had just all
high-fived on the tarmac and said
goodbye
and yeah and then the next thing the
latest doing he's down at the burn
center
you know trying to trying to give
support to elliot you know it was
freaking
freaking rough man that [ __ ] took the uh
that took the win out of ourselves for
the whole task in it you know you're
just wondering like what the hell is
going to happen
so now we got two guys uh wounded with
frags you got joe and elliot
with with what they got going on and
then actually the first week we were
there
you know we had jimmy left over from you
guys he gets he got shot he gets a
grazer
across his nipple so yeah things are
starting to stack up man
you know and elliott was a unknown we
weren't sure if he was going to make it
or not
yeah and i left october 21st and that
was november 19th so you guys had only
been
on the ground without us for under a
month yep yep
and you had all this already stacked up
yep yep
yeah we and not to mention in a way you
are riding in already with
the mental thought of all of our
casualties and our lost guys
you know so you already know that this
is just the way yeah
yeah we had uh you know so
we get past november 19th
we're kind of reorgan and things are
starting to to change at that point i
can't remember if it was november or
december
but you know we had one of the the
tribes out there they had al qaeda come
in and they
killed a couple of their tribesmen and
they were like f al qaeda we want to
come over the
you know u.s side and that was that was
a
a big tipping point out there corregidor
i forget the name of the tribe out there
but the guys went out there and they're
meeting up with the shake and they're
local guys and it was a it was a weird
situation
because at that point those guys were
dropping mortars on corregidor so
there's this friction like i'm
freaking helping these dudes out they
want to join us now they're just
you know the other day they're dropping
mortars on us you know um
so that was that was that was
interesting and then
december time frame we'd set up
uh i think it was right before christmas
we're we're up there around racetrack
and uh the marine corps is doing a big
huge push in through to clear out that
whole area that area was still
pretty much contested when you guys were
there and that was an area we'd operate
in quite a bit
and so we're out there for like i don't
know three four days and this is right
before christmas time we think we're
going to be out there
past christmas and a couple of events
there like the
the moves they were so good at using
dead space you know i remember we're on
a two-story building we got marine corps
snipers in position we're in position
we're spread out
and uh i go to use the bathroom and i'm
looking out this window and there's a
tank down in my corner
and a dude slips out of dead space with
an rpg in
like moosh boom he clacks that thing off
in under three seconds
melts back away and you're like even if
i was on my gun i don't think i
had enough time to to shoot that guy we
had a couple close calls
in that area you know they had some
snipers in vehicles
and so it muffled the sound you couldn't
tell where they were coming from you
know
and when uh you know i took a damn shot
in through our position right at the
12 o'clock so you know we got our
loophole set up and around 762 by
54 big one punches all the way through
the wall right at the 12 o'clock
position so the guy's dead center trying
to get into
our hole where we're at and i just
remember thinking damn man that's
whoever shot that that's a good shot
that's not you know some jv dude making
that shot
um and as i got to tell the story i
forgot about this one but
we had our country boy old charlie he's
out now so i'll say his name on the net
but charlie we're on the
this is all in this three four day
period
and uh we're on the rooftop and it's the
same day that i take that round and
through the 12 o'clock position
and there's muge doing a center peel
down the street
and so like i'm here charlie's position
is over here with his crew
and we got a pilot up overhead and he's
like hey you got some you got bad guys
coming down the street towards you and
you know charlie's just a good old
country boy he's like roger that you
know
he's like frag out he dumps a frag and
it like
hit i don't know how he does it he
throws the frag in the blind throws it
down on the street it hits in between
where these
moves are at and the pilot's more
excited than anyone he's like it's a
direct hit
that's our direct head and i'm like
talking to y'all like charlie what'd you
do so i'll just pop my grenade and throw
it out there you know
it's like roger that dude but you guys
you guys were getting aircraft overhead
inside the city
yeah we you know on the day elliot got
hit we had a
i don't know if it was a 14 or 15. okay
fast movers yeah fast you weren't
getting helos were you
no yeah i don't remember having any helo
though they'd be too slow they'd get
shot down yeah the healers wouldn't
wouldn't come in for us
uh because of that reason they don't
want a freaking black hawk down
scenario unfolding which is which would
happen
yeah the apaches came in one time and
they left and didn't come back yeah they
got they got lit up like it was
crazy it was a crazy amount of volume of
fire we were putting it in a combat
outpost
and they came in they said they want to
support they flew in and it was like
it was freaking crazy yeah they flew
away and didn't come back
we man things were so confusing over
there i remember being out there in
positions and
we had you know these two young ladies
and they're
doing close they're hanging clothes and
then this other what looks like a lady
comes out there and
she's like laying clothes out um
but the third person that came out late
they're just looking everywhere they're
looking for us
and it was a dude dressed like a woman
you know they got the garb over their
head so you can't even
tell but he's constantly looking looking
looking the girls are giggling because
it's
you know it's kind of funny of them i
was like it took me a long time to put
that uh
that picture together what transpired
and i couldn't do it while i was in the
field
you know i was like it was just weird
i'm like all right that had been a dude
trying to find our position stressed as
a woman um and these dudes were just
they were cagey man we were out there in
the papa sector on another uh
mission and it's me and another dude and
we're set up in
in the hole and uh and i remember i'm
looking and a guy's looking at
looking directly at us but he's got like
a three or four year old girl right next
to him
but he's looking in our direction i'm
like that [ __ ] ain't right but he's got
no gun
he's like 2 300 yards away i'm keeping
my eye on him
watching watching watching nothing
happens me and
me and the other guy rotate out of the
hole he gets in there and [ __ ] five
minutes after he gets in the hole we
just started
you know got into the hole man and like
i'm young like dude roll out of there
you know he rolls out but there's [ __ ]
flying everywhere you know and we're
like damn that was close lucky that dude
didn't get hit you know
but that guy was spotting with his
daughter yeah if it
even was his daughter yeah or yes
spotting with a child
he grabbed out and said yeah hold my
hand come over here
boom yeah and if the guy had a gun
i'd have felt comfortable taking a shot
but he doesn't have anything so you're
just like
is this just more weird [ __ ] going on
over here there's so many weird things
going on
weird inexplicable things that are
happening all the time yeah and they're
all look freaking crazy suspicious
yeah i mean we had a isr asset one time
over
flying overhead like is a fast mover or
something
and he's like hey we got we got a
vehicle pulling up like we got a vehicle
so there everyone's looking at this
vehicle i'm looking at this vehicle on
the isr screen
and like it's this looks super suspect
they're stopping they're looking around
they get out
you know open the trunk all right oh
they're opening the trunk open the trunk
you know everyone's on this mode
and then all right they're reaching in
they're reaching they're pulling
something out they're pulling something
out they're pulling out
they're pulling out an object right now
and sure enough like everyone's all
excited and thinking this is like we
need to drop a bomb on this thing and
sure enough they
got out of jack out of the thing and
jacked up their freaking car and
changed the tire and put it all away and
left yeah
and like they tracked them they're they
left they weren't it wasn't like a
a setup you know yeah and and
man it's so difficult to to decipher
what's go really happening yeah and you
get better at it
yeah but it's a tough war to fight
you know it's a tough war to fight you
know like i know when we turned over
with you guys you always talked about
the
hey was a good shoot bad result hey the
what they're doing is lined up with the
enemy procedures you build the story
and you make the best decision you can
with what you're looking at
and sometimes just your point it's
actually legitimate but you don't know
that you know
yeah well that was something i i learned
and stole from
the first the 506 because we had
or they we when we were when we first
got there and we were over with them and
they
had some one of their guys shot and
killed somebody and they were
like the person was out did i forget
what suspicious activity they were doing
but it was like they were digging a hole
in the side of the road
and they shot killed the guy and then
they sent a team out there to inspect
and he was
whatever uh you know he had he was
planning to play i don't know what he
was doing but it was something that was
not the activity that
that the shooter thought it was and i
was talking to their ops officer and he
was like hey you know what this is a
this is a good shot
bad result meaning that the r soldier
was following the proper rules of
engagement
and it turns out that the result of that
shot is bad
even though the shot was good the result
was bad yeah and
and you know it it bothers me so much
when i hear people talk about
you know these uh the us military you
know
causing all these civilian casualties
man we go through such
great lengths to prevent civilian
casualties and put our
soldiers sailors airmen and marine at
such risk
to prevent those casual civilian
casualties from happen
happening but it does happen that's the
reality like it's going to happen
and that's why if you're going to go to
war you better be ready for that yep
you can't go to war thinking oh yeah
don't worry we won't kill any civilians
it's like
you know if you go into war you're
killing civilians yeah
yeah i'm trying to think i know in the
other deployments i did over there we
started doing a lot of
collateral damage assessments before we
did anything
i don't remember doing that when we were
in ramadi because we weren't really
dropping bombs and there was mostly just
ground
um ground units handling business you
know
um but anyways that that became a factor
later on for sure
everything was a cd you know yeah i mean
even even
even when i relieved you in baghdad we
started looking at collateral damage in
terms of like breaching
yeah like okay we're going to breach
this building what's the collateral
damage
could we hurt someone can we are we
going to ruin this
you know how many how many windshields
are we or how many windows in this
neighborhood are we going to blow
out with this explosive breaching charge
and what good does that do
for our overall strategic mission here
if we're the [ __ ] that come in every
night and blow up everyone's house and
windows right
yeah all of a sudden we're not cool yeah
so
sometimes it was like oh okay well maybe
we shouldn't explosively breach walden
how are you gonna execute the mission
and what risk does it put the troops at
because the safest way to do a direct
action mission is to explosively breach
the [ __ ] out of them
shock everyone in the building and like
okay cool
so there's other tactics that we had to
develop to to mitigate the risk but
what i'm saying is we were taking risks
for sure
to try and mitigate and not just us
every when i say we i mean the u.s
military
at large mitigates risk of civilian
casualties by risking
our own casualties that's what we do
and and even as much as we mitigate them
we can't mitigate them all
and civilians are going to die so you
need to think about that
yeah so how did when you guys had that
horrific incident
with elliot and joe then what
that like how did the rest of the
deployment and i know that you guys so
one thing that's really positive is and
part of this transition i don't even
know if you knew this so
we were doing everything we could we we
that whole sons of ambar and
that whole thing started when we were
there and
and then the other thing we were trying
to do is we were trying to get the iraqi
police force built up
and we just started to get it built
as we left and so you guys got the
benefit of the iraqi police force
all of a sudden the local iraqi police
force was
respected they were manned they had
they they understood the neighborhoods
they were tribal most the guys were
tribal guys
and so all of a sudden over a very quick
period of time
the the violence went down a lot yo
absolutely absolutely i remember
the police became a huge factor i think
it was late january early february for
us
they came in they're setting up their
own police stations and combat outposts
but man them dudes were targeted by aq
you mean they had the head police chief
they're
they're trying to car bomb him and his
entire family and they eventually got
him
um but it was it was rough and it
definitely settled down everything i
would say in
by the you know mid
mid january to february somewhere and
there's where things really
settled and good where hey the attacks
are going way down
you know we're still getting the
occasional ied you know they had a
you know an army uh civil affairs they
were going down to
freaking falcon and boom they hit an id
killed all four people
oh yeah that was that was travis patrick
win and he's
was a freaking epic guy that and that
was a major mcclung the
the female marine corps officer who was
just
because they were there when i was there
they were both just freaking awesome
awesome people
just awesome unbelievable that was such
a freaking horrific
situation yeah it's absolutely horrible
but things definitely uh
died down there towards you know january
february time frame
i was in a good place
then you redeploy you came back to
america came back to america
and boom i'm going to work for
jacqueline training
rolled into trade man and that was um
that was awesome yeah that was awesome
did you did you
volunteer to come there what happened
how did you get yeah so before
deployment i know
i was working with our group cmc and
they were doing team level detailing so
he came in he's like hey man what do you
want to do i was like well hey i want to
stay
out i want to stay in the area he's like
what do you think about going to trade i
was like
keep me in eric he's like yeah i was
like hell yeah i'll do it so roger that
man
in it i was looking forward to it you
know and you know that the guy relieved
over there bg he's just a
good dude smart and i think he set up a
good foundation
uh with with what he had so i inherited
a really
a good product yeah he was doing good
[ __ ] yeah no it was uh
it was it was legit and then when you
showed up it was awesome
um and then i mean
what was what was your experience at
trade at like in terms of see now this
is interesting you know i told you that
like the seeds of my experience and
knowledge
were watered heavily and fertilized
heavily
but i was young so now you get to
experience this
in a much in a much more powerful
environment because the training we were
conducting was so much more advanced
then and also you were more advanced and
you were a combat veteran of multiple
combat tours and you were a senior
enlisted guy
so man it was just it was awesome it was
a good experience but i'll tell you what
i went in there
and i'm like holy it's different when
you're responsible for
a live fire range versus you're going
through a live fire range
and so there was there was a lot to that
you know the most stressful
thing for me during land warfare was
doing all the live fire training
because there was definitely a lot of
opportunity for someone to get injured
or wounded
you know you know what i mean and so it
was good and getting up there and
teaching these things
you just learn so much more i mean the
pipeline should be
we need guys in instructor positions but
you need them a budge you also need them
over at
our trade yeah um if there was a way to
split that to where they do
15 months it buds 15 months of trade it
would be ideal there's just
it's not practicable you know um but
going to trade it was an
eye opener and i really started you know
i'd say around 2003 i started
2003 2004 started reading quite a bit
started getting like
i never heard of the last hundred yards
you know we didn't have a portal with
libraries we didn't have guys going
around if you went a training show you
might see it
but i really started building up a good
uh reading block
and i remember talking to you when we
were at trade it and we were reading i
think i just went through
um the maneuver warfare handbook and i
was like man i'm thinking these things
and then you read it and it reinforces
what you were thinking so like now your
confidence just goes through the roof
and i think one of the things we did
good in in
nsw continues to do this is developing
our future leaders i mean think about
when you and i came up we
there was no portal there was no none of
this stuff we've got stuff
hanging hey you want to be a good
tactical leader leader go read your
doctrine go read these books here
and that is going to boost you up and
the guys that are hungry
they're going to go in there and read it
the guys that are you know a little bit
lackadaisical and they don't want to do
it they're going to meet the minimum
standard
but you definitely need to have
something out there to where
you know your high performers are hungry
give it to them so that they
can become uh you know a better leader
so i think we did that good but just
going back to land warfare i think
you know the stress levels they were
high during live fire training the field
training exercises we did were
just badass we're building you know
little wood huts all over the damn place
on those ranges
and uh i think the guys you know i mean
[ __ ] we had a thermal camera out there
at one point and we're videotaping the
guys coming in so they come back and go
through their debrief
we're going this is what you all look
like here's what we're telling you
here's what you look like and the people
see what they look like oh damn check
roger that you know and they're making
some adjustments
but i thought it was good i was
definitely learning a lot while i was
there
i wish i had done that um that
assignment earlier on
in at least a team five training cell
would have boosted me up
a lot you know would you see what did
you notice from the
i mean the crazy thing about it is you
get to it's the best
i i i truly think this i think that
that land warfare training is the best
leadership laboratory in the world
i think that's it i don't think there's
a better leadership laboratory where you
can see leadership in action i really
don't
because you get the whole dynamic
someone might be saying well you know
when uh
you know in some business or in some you
know
uh bureaucratic situation or some
boardroom
you get that part too because you've got
the mission planning that's taking place
and there's no
gunfire going on during the mission
planning but you get the stress
and you get the people that have to make
decisions you get the team arguing with
each other and you get the different
personalities that are coming out
and so you get to watch all this and you
get to learn and you get to see how
people react and you get to see human
nature
over and over and over again and you get
to see
one platoon do it yeah and then you see
another
do the same thing the same i mean we had
all those little uh
pet nicknames for all the different
maneuvers that we knew that
our mooge was gonna do and we so you'd
see a platoon go through
the octopus you see a platoon go through
the corner of death right you'd see
the the trail of tears you'd get to see
how
they would react and you'd see what a
good leader would do
and you'd see how that would turn the
platoon and all of a sudden they'd be
able to get
things together and survive and make it
happen and do a good job
and you see bad leadership and you go
well these guys are just go
it's going to be a suffer fest and so
that that leadership laboratory was just
unbelievably powerful
and and really it was it was powerful
for
for us as instructors because we were
detached and we got to watch it look the
troops
obviously get a ton out of it too but
getting to see it over and over again
was just ridiculous amount of learning
one of the things i i really respected
about land warfare
you got to see people's true character
when they're coming through there
they're up late at night you're under a
lot of stress
whatever you're thinking in your head or
whatever type of attitude you have good
or bad that's coming out
and you really get to see what you're
working with with your platoon you know
yeah
and that's a good precursor because when
you go to combat if you end up going on
deployment you end up getting in real
combat you're gonna see
that that's the only place that's gonna
come out even more is when you go into
combat people start acting crazy
like and i'm not talking about hey in a
gunfight there no i'm talking about
on a day-to-day basis you start seeing
what their character is
they do they want to operate do they
want to hide do they
like you get to see start to see all
that stuff and you'll see it
you'll see it out in the desert in
training you'll see people start to
crack and you'll also see people step up
and you'll see people start to lead and
you see people that are tough
and when you see those good leaders
coming through and look the good leader
could be anyone in the platoon from an
e5
to the to the platoon or the
task unit commander or anyone in between
you have one good leader or two good
leaders in there and they're going to do
a good job
yeah they can be countered by bad
leadership so you can have a good leader
that gets countered by someone that's an
ego jackass
and they the ego jackass can actually
ruin everything
sometimes if you just have one good
leader that's the lpo of one platoon
and he's a really good solid leader he
can carry the whole task unit
now if you put a jackass senior chief in
there or a jackass chief or a jackass
lieutenant he can
he can override two or three squared
away
leaders because he's a knucklehead and
doesn't want to listen and wants to do
everything his way and wants to
you know let his ego run the show it's a
freaking disaster yeah
we saw it was funny we saw quite a few
good leaders come through
probably the most rewarding thing having
guys come through training is they're
coming through they're just starting out
as a unit you know they're figuring some
things out if they haven't been through
another block
and they come in and the growth that you
see that you're providing as instructors
you know as a cadre as a unit
and you see them start here and by the
time they finish after that three four
weeks
they're they're up here 100 the growth
is is tremendous and guess what
the harder the training the harder the
training the more the guys appreciate it
the more growth you have
yeah right that's what i physically saw
happening with
with our with our uh formation yeah
because it was miserable
yes it was freaking miserable it was
freaking hard when you're carrying out
i mean we'd if if a platoon did a bad
job they'd have
12 down men they'd be carrying out 12
down men for
three or four kilometers before they
could finally get a helicopter in there
to pick up and take the wounded then
they still gotta walk the rest of them
gotta walk out
like when you got your ass kicked you
got your ass kicked
and it would sometimes you know that was
another big difference when a when a
leader when the leadership in the task
unit or in the platoon would say
would come back and say hey we screwed
up we better fix it oh man
yeah they would fix it if the k if they
came back and said oh trade that's
cheating
or traded this is this this training is
unrealistic
if they said that they wouldn't improve
yeah and they just fall apart but when
they say
hey we spent too much time on target hey
we didn't cover and move
yeah or hey we didn't give the
priorities correctly
or we didn't have when they came back
and said that recognized and fixed it
they'd come out and a good task unit by
the end
our trade act guys couldn't keep them
under wraps like
they would get the the trade guys would
get their asses kicked because there's
because there's 40 in the back i mean 40
of the
of the platoon guys so they could
freaking
when they would do good cover move you
can't stop them no they're unstoppable
yeah
yeah well that's what i always tell
people hey man the people who utilize
the laws of combat did good
cover and move kept things simple good
communications across the board
prioritized and executed stayed detached
from what was going on
and the guys that utilize decentralized
command where they're allowing fire team
leaders and squad leaders to make
decisions at their level because
you can't be everywhere as the boss
making these decisions
you got to train your you got to train
your your leaders up
put up some guard wells get them to
where they need to be and then you let
them start making decisions you know and
that that's probably like
one of the most beautiful things with
land warfare guys are going out there
they're learning these things
and they're slowly building their
confidence to where when they get to the
field training exercise week and they
start making some of these decisions
then it's even that much more of a
confidence builder you know
it's weird because
you can you can i mean look i would
explain this stuff
ad nauseam right ad nauseum i mean i
would explain it and explain i'd say
look you got to do this you got to do
this you have this
but sometimes man it would just take
like it happening to someone yep and
being
and me sitting there like literally
running over to a fire team leader
and saying hey what are you doing those
guys are freaking running right now you
got to get them down you got to put down
cover fire for them
and them going oh wait a second i get it
yeah and then you'd see this light come
on
or i'd run up to a freaking task unit
commander and be like where
do you want everyone to go right now
what do you want everyone to do
and he'd say we need to get out of here
okay what direction
i said are you going to be able to move
everyone out of here no can you think
your fire teams can start moving
yes tell them where you want them to
move just tell them all and they'll
start making it happen yeah
and you could see the little like all of
a sudden the little light would come on
but sometimes it would just take that
like you have to live you almost have to
live
through it so in some cases some guys
would be like yeah got it cover move
check got it because you learn cover
move day one or
the day one of the teams you learn to
cover and move yeah you better freaking
cover and move yeah
yeah sometimes it took guys a little
while to figure out how to utilize the
train
correctly you know because the the
terrain was a was a factor rockies
small wadis um uneven terrain which was
hard to maneuver and especially when you
got a down man
there was something there too terrain
terrain is the is the next
level right the next level is
oh i don't just know how to cover and
move i just don't know simple i
just don't know prioritize and execute i
don't just know
decentralized command i know how to
utilize the terrain to my advantage
that's the next level up that's the next
level up when you realize oh i can get a
little high ground oh there's a little
dead space oh there's a ravine over here
i can get the guys out
that's the next level and we tried to
teach it in that method you know you
start off doing iods in a flat
you know spot and then all of a sudden
you start to get used to rain
but when the leadership when the t when
the pl
when the whole task unit when a fire
team leader knows how to use terrain
and then all the fire team leaders know
how to use terrain all of a sudden we're
in a whole different spot
yeah we're in a whole different spot so
yes the terrain
is so freaking critical yeah wow
absolutely a little bit of high ground
yeah yeah we had guys down in that micro
train
doing good things yeah tough stuff on
the body
uh and we had i mean we had rain we had
rangers out there helping us
oh which was awesome dude those guys
they brought a lot in
the rangers we had out there they had
all kinds of uh
both of them came from leadership
assignments within their
their ranger unit and they had a lot of
reps man they brought a lot to the table
they had all kinds of good info man we
were eating we were just like on standby
keep it coming keep it coming keep it
coming
it's always it's one of the the worst
one of the bad things one of the worst
things about the the seal teams
is we don't come from an infantry
background
yeah you know we're not soldiers yeah
we're not infantry
where we're so we don't have that skill
set
and you can get lucky and you can get
brushed up against it i got
i got at least brushed up against it
doing args with the marines and being
like okay i at least
understand what an infantry platoon is
because if you're a regular seal new guy
you don't know what the hell an infantry
platoon is you have no idea you think a
platoon is 16 guys you know
in a platoon but but yeah so those so in
the army
you have that infantry background in the
marine corps you have that infantry
background it's so helpful
so having like rangers out there with us
who are freaking great guys
by the way yeah um and they bring that
that infantry background and
and they were stoked too they were they
freaking they
loved our training yeah they were
awesome the both those guys had a lot of
reps in uh
afghanistan i remember right and i know
where the the one guy came in and he was
really tightening up
uh our helicopter procedures um
just you know with he covered so much
like damn i didn't think about that
you know all my deployments were uh to
iraq at that point
but yeah good dudes man did you read
about face back then
oh yeah so i read it when i got to uh
trade it you know you had that as your
bible
and uh damn what was the guy's name i
had him in here uh
there was another colonel that uh he's
got a page on
four page uh four or something in uh
on in about face but the the guy was
just a beast
oh glover jones that's him yeah dude
that guy had so many good nuggets on the
page and a half he had yeah
but i remember reading through that page
402 half worth
and he just has some nuggets in there
he's got like 15 things that he covers
you know strive to do small things well
yeah be a doer and a self-starter um you
know
the one that that i always hit home with
me because i think it's so true is uh
what is it the two you know in order to
be a good
two good characteristics of the leaders
you've got to be a good communicator and
you've got to be a good uh writer
and and the writing piece comes into
play as you start moving up in your
upper level
leadership and management positions
because you're writing evals for the
guys
and i remember being a traitor and you
were kind of like hey man if you guys
bring me
an eval and the thing requires minor or
requires major surgery i'm only going to
be able to do so much to it to make it
better
but you bring me an eval that's dialed
in pretty damn tight
i'm going to get it over the line it's
going to be a beautiful piece of work
it's going to be a piece of art
and you were getting into people's [ __ ]
on it you were you were not a happy
camper because there was like all these
evils coming in yeah
but it's so true when you think about it
hey how do we take care of our people
a way is into our evaluation system
making sure
the right people are getting promoted
and through awards those all requiring
require some type of writing skill right
one freaking
series one year of evaluations probably
the first year that you were there
yeah the [ __ ] that you guys turned in
and i had no choice i didn't get him
till too late
and i just had to i just had to do nine
days in my office just rewriting every
single one of them
and that's why the next year early yeah
i said hey everyone write me the eval
for your best guy
and then i brought you guys you you were
in this group right i brought you guys
into the into the conference room and
posted them up on the screen
i made you guys read your sentences to
me and you guys
you guys were just like you know like
the very first sentence that each guy
read it would just be like
uh this blah blah just a [ __ ] sentence
and i'd be like all right how does that
sound like not good
but that worked so well yeah because
then everyone realized oh i should
actually read this stuff i should
actually read it aloud to myself i
should actually see if these sentences
make sense and
it just helped everybody so so it helped
me
because now you guys were all turning in
squared away stuff
which then i could what to what would
you say turn into a piece of art
i don't know if i could quite go that
far i believe in quotations a piece of
art
chocolate we got an artist on the net
over here
yeah uh glover john's from hackworth too
and he wrote a book called the clay
pigeons of st
low which we covered on this podcast and
it's written it's hard to tell because
he wrote it in the third person talking
about himself
as if he was a different person but it's
about him then it's a great book and it
gives all kinds of leadership lessons as
well uh
one of the things i want to camp out
real quick on uh on hackworth
one of the things is i was reading
through that book and it took me i think
six months to get through it because i
think
it's a big book but it really reinforced
you know when you're coming in
is a leader at any level when you're new
to that leadership assignment you're
always uncomfortable so you're trying to
figure out
am i making the right decision and when
you're going through and you're reading
some non-fiction that pertains to your
field your field craft
it just reinforces what you're thinking
and i remember after reading about face
the maneuver warfare handbook i came out
i was like damn
a lot of these decisions i was uncertain
about it reinforced that i was making
the right decision
so how do you become better you read
that stuff before you get in those
leadership positions
and who's responsible for for just
throwing that out the leadership
you know if you're in a leadership
position out there what are you doing to
develop your future leaders
you have people that want to want to
take your your job
what are you doing to develop them and
you look across the world like we got
covered everywhere you can get in a car
accident who's the next person in line
that's going to take your job who is
that person
and what are you doing to develop them
you know we've gotten way better over
the years in the military than to still
be doing this
you think about that it's pretty
powerful you know yeah dude jp
sent because i get i gave uh jp
a copy of at least i think i gave it to
him anyways he got a copy of the new
edition of about facebook the forwarding
and everything and so he's like
sending me highlighted passages and he's
and he's not happy yeah and he's like
bro i cannot believe that you didn't
make me read this
when i was a you know when i was 23 or
22.
and i'm like dude i'm sorry like i'm a
horrible leader because there's so much
information in there oh man yeah
and i just ripped it off wholesale
wholesale just ripped it off
and it's like why didn't i share that
yeah
and and part of me was i just didn't
think team guys had any
desire to read anything you know because
most team guys didn't
most team guys were like beer
you know what i did with my about face
when i got back over to when i got over
to team seven
i gave it out to one of our younger
tactical see that's
here he's like that's a big book i'm
like yes you need to read that
and then when you're done with it you
need to pass it on to someone else do
you think you read it
i don't know man it's such a big book i
don't know
it's good and here's the thing we always
talk about
making hard calls you look at those
decisions he made in there
those were he was going to be hated he
knew that going in he didn't care he
knew what the right thing to do
was he made the right calls and you know
he wind up saving a lot of lives with
his guys from it yeah well see there's a
little
nuance there in what you said
he had to make hard calls he knew that
he would be
hated in the short term he knew that
there would be resistance
yeah but he knew in the end he would be
admired and he would be loved
because he would be able to keep his
guys alive and he knew that that
what what would shine through is the
fact that he cared about his men
yep that's what would shine through and
believe me when we had
general mukayama on i was so
uh not really worried but like going
into it here i'm gonna meet a guy that
worked for a freaking hack
and what is he gonna say yeah like is he
gonna be like well you know hack
made himself out to be a little bit more
than he was or hack talked a good game
but that really wasn't the guy
he was i didn't know what he was going
to say yeah but dude he was just
100 100 percent hack was the man
and he was a company commander when he
when when hack was a battalion commander
i mean that's
that's the that's the leadership wow so
he you know
what you know what i said did you know
who hack was he goes everybody knew who
hack was
damn and like that attitude yeah
and and i said you know what how did you
what was it that made me goes everything
like the way he's carried himself
the way he looked the way he had his he
had his hair he's like he had his head
shaved and he just looked like
this guy's just freaking squared away
from day one
but so you're gonna make because because
one thing i don't like and
leif and i have talked about this on the
podcast is uh
the someone thinking well you know i'm
in charge so i'm gonna be hated and
that's okay it's like
no that's actually not okay if you're
hated by your troops that's a freaking
problem
that means you're doing something wrong
for your troops
for to take over a a a unit
or take over a team or take over a
position and say all right we're going
to start making some adjustments
now one thing that's different too in
hack's case when he took over the 439th
is he took over
a disaster a known disaster he had to
come in there and kind of swing the
hammer a little bit oh
he had to bring out the flamethrower
yeah he had barbara do some barbecue he
had to
do some barbecuing but he also
eventually you know anyone would do
anything you know like talking to
general mukuyama those guys would do
absolutely anything for
anything and even the freaking even the
draftees would do anything for hackword
like they loved them
yeah and it's kind of like you said
earlier when people go through hard
training
they appreciate it and they love the
training more when you are
disciplined with your troops when you're
hard on your troops
they respect you yeah and they respect
themselves
and you start to get this camaraderie
that you need
you know i think a hackworth i think of
uh like you said a dude showing up
right haircut right uniform just
everything he's communicating lines up
with his actions
and the guys just had been like damn
does this guy do anything wrong
you know what i mean does he sleep
what's going on with this dude and when
you look at that you're like
hey my margin of error is going to be
small because this this
dude's doing everything he's saying yeah
you know it's
uh powerful that's leadership by example
that's how you got to roll
yeah 100
uh what anything else from trade at no
man no it's all good
christmas in the desert christmas in the
desert oh yeah yeah yeah so i remember
uh an island man we were wrapping up and
we had a it was a good run the troop
came through
good energy levels and we're getting
ready to go home
and uh you came and you said that wasn't
bad guys
and i was like all right let me put that
through my enlisted decryption
device up here what jocko's saying is
good job have a good christmas
he loves you all and you're like cook
you gave a little chuckle out of there
so i got you kind of being huggy bear
there right before christmas the spirits
were good
oh so i said that wasn't bad and that's
that's as good of a compliment as you're
gonna get out of me
yes yeah i had to translate it for him
but yeah
let's check maybe
compliments weren't my strong point they
were not
uh i got some recordings of some of
those debriefs
somebody's somebody's hooking me up uh
one of one of my buddies
he's he just texted me a a couple weeks
ago he's like hey
somebody gave me recordings of your
debriefs yeah he's like
me you're gonna want to hear him like
chat yeah
i remember being on target out there and
uh this unit was
maneuvering i forget what siphon we're
at but
one of the guys communication is so long
hey i need you to grab your guys and
move to the mountain like in black hawk
down you're like what the hell why don't
you you know what are you talking about
man it's just crazy
talk you know yeah i would just hit
record on my voice recorder during those
things and play it back for people like
listen to yourself
i'd be like hey you need to keep
yourself a little clearer more simple
clear and concise i was keeping it
simple oh really listen to this
here's you telling your troops peel
right hey i need everyone to blah blah
blah blah freaking ridiculous
yeah yep freaking totally ridiculous
yeah
yeah that was crazy so then where'd you
go yep so
after that headed back over to uh or
headed to team seven
and at that point it already made master
chief so i was going there's the ops
master chief senior listed guy and then
i got pegged
to do so i went back there in what uh
october
2009 october 2009
just finished up the senior enlisted
academy they're like hey this big one
they're trying to pump as many people as
they can over in afghanistan so i got
hit with a joint individual augment
headed out to a small out station out in
afghanistan i was the senior enlisted
leader out there which was
a good experience it was the first time
at that point where i really worked in a
joint environment so the
my boss was a full bird colonel he was
sf dude
good guy i learned a lot from him he'd
been in like 32 years he was prior
enlisted and they worked his way up to
the ranks just salty old dog
and then we had you know the army air
force uh
marine corps out there everyone and then
we had you know quite a few
military officers from different
countries you know we had afghanistan
and a few other surrounding countries in
there
um in in our our primary goal was
to fusion intel and then you know we had
some reconnaissance platforms
up overhead and you know they were doing
they're doing their stuff in some other
countries
but it was good and uh that was the
first time i really appreciated
our special forces unit and i was
working with another senior enlisted
leader he was in another country
and he was like hey man here's what we
got going on and me and him would
communicate back and forth you know
like once or twice a week he's like hey
i got my sf battalion we're training up
this
and he's like here's our numbers and i
was like hey wait a minute you guys
have this many you know odas over there
and you've trained up you've man trained
and equipped 2
000 of these soldiers he's like yeah and
i was like holy [ __ ] dude that's a big
deal man that's like
our formation in his w in action over
there you know yeah like
by that you mean all of the west coast
seal
and all support yeah in action yeah and
so these guys are training up these guys
and they're going in and they're
fighting
the taliban and he's got his oda's doing
i was like holy [ __ ] that's
a pretty badass man um so it was a good
deployment like not much going on
outside the wire the area i was in was
actually like yeah i was like cool i
just got out an island then i go over
there and i'm like damn i'm back in the
island the terrain is exactly exactly
the same there was some hub hub about
us losing our desert training facility
someone else is going to take it over
and i made this this slide show did i
ever show you that
i made a slideshow and it was pictures
of afghanistan
and pictures of our desert training
facility side by side and you
literally couldn't tell the difference
wow and i was like you've got to be
kidding me if you think that this isn't
the greatest
training site for for us to have
yeah yeah yeah so anyways that was a
short deployment at that point i'm the
ops master chief but i'm deployed
come back uh six months later i got home
right before
july and then as i'm back at the team
the team's going through unit level
training
and then we're prepping up for our
deployment in uh
march time frame and that was a weird
deployment like we winded up
some of us wound up back over in iraq
and so this is 2010
2011 time frame now and we're breaking
down
iraq yes yeah we're waiting for our four
platoons that are still
in san diego to get over to afghanistan
and they're going over to do
village stability operations so
get over to iraq and that you know that
deployment um
it was a long one it was like eight and
a half months long um
a lot of you know the unit we were
working with had all the bells and
whistles and it was it was good man so a
lot of good things happening
our guys wrapped up quite a few bad guys
and uh it was it was a good learning
experience it was the first time i was
in
you know a professional jock setting
where you're actually
seeing everything unfold in real time
all the assets you can imagine
um you know and our guys did some good
targeting they got a couple bad guys
have been
after for four or five years so it was
good then came back off that deployment
then took over as the
team you know command master chief so
explain what a team command master chief
is
well our primary job is to
initially is to set up the platoons
you're working with the you know
the top five of the team the commanding
officer the exo
your operations department you know the
senior listed in there and the
in the ops boss um
and your primary functions are manning
training and equipping the sale team and
you're the senior enlisted
leader um and tactical advisor to
the commanding officer your primary goal
is training up all these
you're not training uh educating and
training
you know your uh your platoon chiefs and
task unit
uh senior enlisted advisors and junior
officers
and so you take over this position and
you you start
building platoons yeah yeah and
i always used to say about platoons
let's say there's a magic number
let's say the number number is 20.
yeah in your top four in a platoon
so your lpo your assistant platoon
commander your platoon commander and
your platoon chief
that number's gotta equal 20. when you
add them all together
yeah yeah so that means if you have a a
a platoon chief that's like a 16 because
he's just a badass
cool you can give him a platoon
commander that's like a two and a
lpo that's a one if you have a platoon
chief that's like a
you know maybe a a six well you gotta
give him a platoon commander that's
maybe like a seven and you gotta even it
out
what you don't want to do is make sure
first of all you got to make sure that
the number gets to 20.
because if it doesn't get to 20 you're
going to have issues
then then you've got to complement
strengths and weaknesses you know if
you've got a guy that's got a bunch of
tactical experience but he's horrible at
paperwork well cool
you know uh put him with a person that's
good at good paperwork
so there's a lot of balancing in in
there that you need to do
absolutely and i know uh our 20
when we formed up the team in 2010 we
went with some heavy platoons with the
idea we're gonna go back in afghanistan
and and one of the things with our our
training and deployment schedule is that
there's a lot of lag time in there
so things are always changing and i was
like man
when we get back and i'm forming up the
team i want to make sure just to your
point all these platoons are balanced
out
um you know when you go heavy in some
platoons that means you're going to be
lighting the others
yeah and that comes that comes at a cost
and really what i wanted was
you got however many platoons you have
at a sale team you should be able to
pick up
any one of those platoons and snap them
in no matter
where you know where you're going what
the mission is they should all be
pretty balanced out equally with
experience in the platoon
leadership yeah your check and here's
another thing to be careful of
to watch out for you you're trying to
get to 20
don't build a platoon with a leadership
level 40. yeah because
it's probably not going to work the way
you think it is what you're going to end
up with is a bunch of big personalities
like you take the strongest possible oic
the strongest possible chief the
strongest possible
uh lpo and the strongest what you're
going to end up with is people that
they all want to freaking stab each
other in the back they all want to be
the guy they'll want it they have such
big egos and it just turns into a
nightmare
yeah so building the stacked platoon
leadership is generally not a good call
yeah and you're good even even if it
happened if you actually had such
exceptional
individuals that they actually did work
well together
well then you're it's bad that you have
them all together because like you said
now you're not balancing out the rest of
the teams because
because you should take those
exceptionally because for
for a for a level 20 individual leader
actually for for a level 17
individual leader to work with
another high performing leader that
other leader needs to be at 20.
yeah because that the person that's a 20
and 20 instead of a 17
the difference between a 17 and a 20 is
that 17 can
can subordinate their ego that's the
difference because when you take two
people that are eight teens
they're missing quality that they don't
have is that they don't they don't know
how to
work with other people and subordinate
their ego yeah that's what gets you to a
freaking level 20 yourself yeah yeah
yeah yeah the balanced out platoons
are are key for the entire team it's
goodness and you think about it
so if i'm bringing in a platoon and you
know we really spread out our guys with
with two and three platoons because
those guys are developing the next set
of leaders below them
you know the platoon chief and lpo and
everyone's got to develop the other guys
too but
those guys have the most impact when the
leadership's gone they're the guys that
are around
and they're showing them what right
looks like so we crossdecked you know
quite a few guys
got everything uh balanced out good and
overall you know
our deployment was uneventful for that
one went over to centcom
um and we were on standby to stand by
you know that was
after benghazi at happy so the new
normal was hey be on standby in case
there's a crisis in there if crisis
comes up we want to have
special operations postured to go handle
an embassy type event um
and it was good so for that deployment
we winded up you know in and out of the
embassy
quite a bit which was good because that
i was like oh i've never been an embassy
before
so you're talking directly to the
ambassador and a whole new world
yeah you got to be professional you got
to have your suit on and you know you
can't drop any f-bombs out there
yeah it's a whole new world yeah so it
was a really good
learning experience although nothing
happened i don't say this we got
postured
you know we had a a unit over into a
neighboring country
and that country was you know uh they
were going through a withdrawal process
and our unit still stayed in position
but we were going to reinforce that unit
so we
were staged we had to stage so we
brought in the aircraft which
you know we're going through a
full-blown rehearsal like we're thinking
we're going to launch our guys
and you know our my biggest takeaway
from that deployment was like hey these
relationships we have with the embassy
they matter because all we had to do was
call up there because we had a tight
relationship and they tell us to say
here's what's going on
the ambassador's working with the prince
and the prince and they're going through
this whole thing do we want to launch
out here do we not want to launch out of
here
um so it was good you know it was boring
but it was a
good learning experience yeah and for
for people that don't
uh really know too much about this world
there there can be
and usually is a lot of tension between
the state department which is the
ambassadors and whatnot and
the military yeah because the
state department wants to solve things
diplomatically yeah that's what their
life is right
and the military we think we can solve
things militarily
so there's tension yeah there's often
tension between those two
sides but if you remember that hey we
all have the same goal right we all have
the goal of
stability and security and overall peace
so if we understand that we're working
towards the same goal let's figure out
the best way to go about it and those
tensions look hopefully we can
overcome yeah because they can cause to
they can cause some really bad things to
happen
you know there can be times where the
military should be used
and if the relationship was good the
military would be used yeah and there's
some times where the military shouldn't
be used
yeah and if the relationship is bad the
military gets used even though it really
shouldn't be used
yeah so once again forming good
relationships
is it's just freaking critical no
absolutely
especially in that environment more so
than than ever you know
hey going back into when we were forming
up you know one of the first things we
did
is you know what grabbed in our goat
locker you know our our enlisted uh
formation e79
and we went through roles and
responsibilities in
my the cmc i had at the time when i was
my task unit
uh when i was attacking a senior listed
advisor he went through and i don't know
how much you played in the roles and
responsibilities
he developed or if they crossed after
what but he went through every position
so i'd already had something that i'd
kept for geez
what is this uh four years now four or
five years later
and i've got it and i go through and i'm
i'm tweaking the verbiage in there
to fit to you know to art to our air our
time
got it yeah and so go through roles and
responsibilities with the goat locker
and our tactical level leaders
hey here's my expectations as a leader
and
and we had your jocko brief on there so
i had a little reading folder on our
drive
here's what's in there read this [ __ ]
it's going to make you a better leader
and i think for the most part our guys
did like we didn't have too many
missteps
for that um for that work-up cycle and
deployment you know
things were relatively contained you
know like
no kooky [ __ ] no big events yeah
setting expectations is definitely solid
and in the in the
seal version of the jocko brief there's
a slide that was roles and
responsibilities
by person yep like
task unit commander here's what you're
doing and i went right on down the line
and i'm sure you guys had to adjust it
too
but the point is and the reason i don't
give it really in the civil
because i don't give it i don't give
roles and responsibilities part of the
brief
because i don't know what the roles and
responsibilities are in this
construction company or
in this manufacturing company or in this
financial company right it changes it
shifts
but in a sealed platoon in a steel task
unit i knew what the rules and
responsibilities were and listen
and here's something i used to explain
like if you're
the platoon chief and you're supposed to
be
the the person that's handling the
tactical situation
okay if the officer is supposed to be
looking at the next move that we're
going to take
hey listen chief if your officer is not
capable of doing that
you better get your lpo trained up so he
can handle the tactical situation so you
can go and
and figure out what you're going to do
next so so we have to be able to not
just do
like our specific job our role and
responsibility
but if we have to inside of our platoon
we might have to say hey you know what
chief
you handle this over here you know if i
get a chief that's not super dynamic on
target
and i got an lpo that's a badass i'll go
hey
hey lpo you're gonna be you're gonna
you're gonna be responsible for this
stuff you're gonna be responsible for
the assault
chief you're gonna be responsible for
the marshaling yeah
okay cool got it you're like that's okay
it doesn't matter now look don't let
your ego get in the way
yeah because the cheap i'm supposed to
be in charge of the assault cool you're
not good at it
yeah of course i'd be much more gentle
about it what i would say
is hey you know well the thing is i want
the lpo to get some experience so we're
going to let him
handle some of these right now and see
how he does and
in the meantime you can just kind of
handle the marshalling over here you
know with the
with the aoic so but yeah those roles
responsibilities so
the fact that you laid those out early
lets everyone know what the expectation
is lets everybody know where you stand
right lets everybody know like hey i
don't put up i'm not going to put up
with this
i'm not going to put up with that i'm
not going to put up with the other thing
yeah if you're out of line
come you better come and tell me what's
going on if i get blindsided
there's going to be problems so all
those all those things
absolutely like that's a great point
setting those expectations of
what you ex what what you need what you
want
what your standards are you set those
out of the gate it's going to align
people
real quick yeah and then you model them
you got to model them yeah you got to do
what you're saying
oh yeah if you're if you're not you
might as well just freaking
just not even put out the word if you're
gonna say hey everyone be squared away
and you're gonna act like a jackass
just don't even put it out yeah it just
clears everybody else
dumb move and then what
and then what so finish up that
deployment come back and then i go and
work at our headquarters
for our uh forest master chief which was
an
awesome guy at the time learned a
truckload from him which i'd a which i'd
be able to use for my next two positions
and so at the headquarters element you
know what i have on here
let me just go back one real quick the
headquarters element was was good
because it was the first time i'm
outside of that that seal team
you know whether it's training or just
seal
you know um mission you're up at the
headquarters element you know i was in
the same
office you were but i'm working for the
force you're working for the admiral so
it's
a very similar line did you do how long
did you work there for uh
right around less than a year and a half
got it but it was enough
we're ready to get out of there after 12
months but here's what i would say
i wish i would have done that position
earlier on
probably like as a chief or a senior
chief but
what does right look like where does it
fit the training i think would have
priority because that's going to set you
up tactically
[Music]
but going up there you're like holy cow
your aperture just
opens wide up with actually how things
work
you know with uh with seal platoons
going over into afghanistan into iraq
how all that stuff works the you want
more gear here's the here's the process
to procure the gear
and you're going through all that and
one of the things the guy i worked for
did is he was up there and he like
he laid out initiatives hey here's the
initiatives i want to get over the line
and then
i was the guy you know when he's on
travel back
at the the black palace trying to move
these things forward as you know as
quickly as possible
without missing anything so it was it
was a good experience and the guy worked
where he had over 30 years and
he bounced around just he was a good
dude man yeah learned a lot from him
yeah well you're right i did work we
worked in the exact same
front i call it the front office and and
for sure
when you start to see you start to see
how small of a role right
like you're small there's like there's
like the whole
military that's the first time you get a
taste of like did you go to the pentagon
did you go on travel with your boss i
went back to uh socom
i didn't travel that much with those
guys so i was going to the panic
bro the pentagon yeah i was i was i was
you know sitting in in the back in the
back of the meeting
with socom you know over and over again
and hearing the word
being put out and seeing them seeing
that the handwritten notes from the
secretary of defense
yeah you know what i'm saying like all
of a sudden you realize how big this
machine
is yeah and and that puts things in
perspective
for you and yes you learn a lot about
you know how to make things happen and
how
well not how to make things happen but
how things happen yes and then you can
at least
provide some level of influence on
trying to hopefully make things happen
yourself
because that's a big understanding it
makes all the difference in the world
because now you know how to navigate it
yeah and you also know like i'm
there's no point getting frustrated
about this thing over here because i can
at least explain to the troops hey this
is why this is happening
i know it seems crazy but guess what the
money that's getting spent for weapons
right now was actually allocated
five years ago yeah
and so if you're going to be mad about
it that's fine but it's not going to
help
yeah yeah that and that was issues i
remember we were getting gear
three four years later that was designed
for
the previous three four years and it was
already obsolete you're like i don't
i can't even use this stuff right now
you know but it was good and i remember
being up there in 2015 and i think that
was when you and leif sent your first
published copy of extreme ownership up
there for approval oh yeah well then it
wasn't a published copy it was probably
like a manuscript
that's what it was yep so i got me a
copy of that oh really got the early one
i got the early one so i read through i
didn't know what to expect you know and
back then everyone's going hey man
people are on their net writing books
i'm like oh let's see what jacqueline
labor write about here a little courtesy
copy
i remember picking up marie i'm like
damn this is really good because the way
you guys
translated into the business world was
just you know
it made sense you know so and plus you
recognized it all
yeah from from the jocko brief which is
yeah you know basically where it all
came from yeah
yeah and your guys the way you wrote it
the position on it was from a humility
standpoint which
people are gonna appreciate that so it
was good man yeah i know that was a
that was a big um obstacle to overcome
mentally yeah you know like
uh for me it was massive you know i
can't speak for life
but like for me i mean we just talked
opened this whole thing up about talking
about reputation yeah
and all of a sudden you know you can you
can destroy your reputation
by becoming that guy yeah we wrote that
book and
you know and and so that was horrible
that was a horrible
uh experience to go through it's like
walking into the unknown and
you can't look and you can't
there's look when you write a book
it is not a humble act right like
there's no
there's it's like saying hey i'm gonna
go freaking uh
uh start a podcast get a designer suit
yeah or start a podcast
hey i'm gonna go get a designer suit but
it's not for it's not for me
yeah like it doesn't work or hey i'm
going to start a podcast and talk a
bunch
like what do you got to talk about dude
so to say you're going to write a book
or you're going to start a podcast or
you're going to
put a spotlight on yourself is basically
what you're doing that's that's what i'm
saying
right when you write a book you're
putting a spotlight on yourself
look at me yeah and and there's no
it doesn't matter what that book says
yeah at least at the initial impression
like you you you are
putting a spotlight on yourself and i
hated that and
it was really it was hard to overcome
that yeah but then you think
here we are working with these civilian
companies yeah and they are
being able to move forward
and execute better and it's like you
know what
the stuff that we learned is probably
worth teaching yeah
yeah the stuff that we learned is people
need to hear it
and then uh one of the the admiral
you know i kind of had that kind of
conversation with him
and he says he said uh he goes you know
what jonco
we are quiet professionals we are not
silent
professionals and some of the stories
need to be told
and some of the lessons need to be
taught yeah and
the way you're doing it is the way it
should be done
yeah and and that was real um you know
obviously that was
about as much reassurance as i could get
and then and then you know just having
uh
having friends that read read the book
in the in the teams and
were like bro legit and then
and then same thing with the podcast
like when i started bro and i started
with a podcast when all my friends
started like
calling me like dude that podcast was
sick and everyone like
that's when i was super stoked you know
because you feel horrible
uh and you feel like you're shining a
spotlight on yourself and
what i realized was that
people saw that i was actually trying to
shine a spotlight not on me but like
on the community not even just our
community but
the army the the marine corps like
everyone that is out there
working hard is where where the
spotlight was
trying to be shined it's just that i
happen to hold it yeah and it's pretty
sketchy to pick that thing up bro
think about this think about if there
were podcasts going on in the 90s
when we were coming up where we could
learn and go and get information on
books to read and
lessons learned from people that were in
vietnam that are talking hey here's some
things we jacked up we had a blue on
blue i wish i'd have done this
here's what i did as a leader that was
jacked up i wish i would have you know
came over here to talk to echo on this
thing
i mean how much better would we have
been we didn't have we had [ __ ] man
we had nothing and and that's um
believe me i think about that all the
time i mean even when i when mike
thornton came on
yeah and and we did a full debrief
i was like i was in the seal teams for
20 years yeah
and i never got that debrief i never
read that debrief never saw
didn't know all those lessons that he
learned yeah
and it's like wait a second that's so
wrong i felt
horrible yeah and so you know what now
it's like oh you can bring on roger
hayden because roger hayden taught me
stuff
yeah but how is a new guy going to learn
about roger hayden and his lessons
yeah yeah you know and it's not even
just lessons about
hey cover move or hey keep it simple
it's lessons about hey when this
happens when you lose a guy
when you get a guy badly wounded when
you get somebody that's
you know acting a certain way when
someone's losing combat like all those
lessons
yeah yeah being able to to
learn them is freaking so powerful yeah
it'll only help people out in the future
you know it's good i mean when i had
james webb on
who was you know naval academy
marine corps navy cross uh you know
secretary of the navy
but when we got done and i mean he
he he wrote the book of fields of fire
incredible book
and it's sort of the book that all
vietnam
movies are based on yeah all every movie
about vietnam is based on that book it's
one way or another
and it's based and that book is is a
thinly disguised autobiography
but when we got done we walked out and
he was like
i never got debriefed like that no one
ever debriefed anything
anything that i did in vietnam like that
wow and he goes
you know i wrote there's some stuff
written down in some library in the
12th floor of the pentagon you know bro
alpha because no one's ever gonna read
that
and and to be able to debrief like that
it's yeah he's like thank you and and
his son was in freaking ramadi wow wow
so yeah there's a i i'm i'm saying
do believe me i mean i meet i meet
marines and army guys and team guys all
the time they're like oh yeah
episode this episode is freaking awesome
because just what you just said
we didn't get that opportunity yeah to
be able to get the debriefs
from people and hear these lessons yeah
and it's so we're so lucky to be able to
do that
it's a powerful learning tool you know a
lot of things to do just to your point
in the military translate right over
into the business world
for everyone to learn from you know
so then what'd you get done you got done
with war com whatever yeah so got done
with the
war com and uh went over and uh at that
time we were
doing rotations with uh combined joint
special operations task force
task force that goes into iraq and then
you know the deal with the siege of soda
you know they're in charge of the
maneuver elements yeah so basically this
is a group that's in charge of all the
special operations
in a area in this case iraq yeah yep yep
so went up there and i think we had
you know you're working with all these
other countries and they're reporting to
you we're
working together as one big team one big
unit i think we had in between
800 and 1100 people with the siege of
soda and guys are dispersed everyone
this is a
a point in iraq where you know isis has
a foothold up in mosul
and we've got you know it was the first
time i actually worked with uh marsoc
we had uh their msots and their msoc out
there along with the
o5 headquarters they were up north and
we had our nsw unit and they were
co-located with us
um there in baghdad
and so it was uh it was a good
experience you know and we're figuring
out hey how are
we going to take take uh down mosul
you know there it's been several
rotations before us where everyone's
just waiting one of their iraqis going
to want to do it one of iraqi's going to
want to do it
and that came to a head on our
deployment which was good
um and so finally we get approval guys
come in there and so what year is this
this is 2016. 2016. so
you know uh guys go in there and start
clearing out mosul
you know and at some point you know one
of our seal units rotated out and jay
and his
formation rotated in which was awesome
jay's team was
was awesome him and his uh commanding
officer did a great job building that
out
you know they were it was you know one
of the best seal teams i've i'd seen
um so it was good anyways they come in
and
start clearing mosul me and my boss we
push up to
uh erbil and then out of erbil we were
running a a
small jock out of there so we were
co-located with
god i forget the sea jock and the sea
jock was the one
who could clear air space to drop
ordnance and we needed to be co-located
with him
to help deconflict in case anything got
snagged up
um so anyways there was a lot of kinetic
fighting
in there going on at that point but a
good experience we're working with
i think seven or eight different
countries first time i've been inside of
see desoto working like that you're up
in the
upper leadership and management position
you know taking on everything that's
going on
i'm trying to provide my my boss with
the the best advice i can on
you know what i recommend um you know
the boss i had back then he's an admiral
now but he was just
squared away just even-tempered guy
people
loved him the other countries loved him
like hey where'd you get this guy i'm
like that's my first time working on it
he's dialed in he had a great reputation
you know
um so it was it was it was a good
deployment you know
and probably the things that weighed the
most on that deployment
is i'd never really been a part of uh a
ramp ceremony
to where you're like you're leading this
thing and uh
we had one of our warrant officers and
this was our first ramp ceremony
and so we had a pilot that was shot down
i want to say it was 2006 time period
and his remains were never recovered and
our warrant officer went off this and
he's working with the shake the sheik's
going hey we got the remains if you want
them
and they start doing negotiations and
then shakes like hey we want
this amount of money and our guys going
back and forth
and in just a point up front i want to
make is when you assign
the right person you know the right
talent to that
to what you're trying to accomplish you
can
get a lot over the finish line and i'm
saying that up front because
there was other agencies that had worked
with this shake to try to get the
remains back they couldn't get it over
the finish line
but here was a guy with never done this
before the right temperament the right
attitude
went in there and was playing a little
hard ball with this guy played a little
softball over here
and he got it over the finish line you
know we winded up you know
you know negotiating with the shake we
got the remains back
we went through our ramp ceremony back
here and then we got the
you know the remains back to the u.s so
the you know that officer could be
properly uh buried and he was he was a
a pilot that had been shot down um so
it was powerful felt good you know felt
good and then we had a few other
ramp ceremonies we know we lost uh this
was one of one of jay-z or these bubbas
but
he was hit you know up there in mosul
with an ied and he was killed and so we
did a ramp ceremony film brought him
back
and we had one other guy and i want to
i'll tie this back into ramadi but the
the third guy we had he was you know
he's doing some stuff in another country
he was hit hard he was killed and we
brought him
back to us and it was like the night
before thanksgiving back in the u.s
and in ramadi we were operating right
before
christmas and you know the siege of soda
commander pulled us out and we were
pissed off we were like what the hell
man we were planning on being here in
through christmas eve through christmas
and the siege of soda commander back in
2006 said hey man i don't want to report
back to anyone's family that
their son was wounded or killed you know
before christmas
and then here we are you know damn near
10 years later
in in iraq and this guy gets killed
right before
thanksgiving and his family's over with
the other family or his wife and kids
are over with their family and
they got to get notified we're coming
back here going through all our
procedures
to make sure everything's tight and he's
getting his uh proper respect before we
send him out
but those things like when you're
putting an american on
an aircraft in a casket with the flag
draped over man it just
it's a gut punch man it sucks it sucks
man
it's something i never you know wish
upon anyone
um and it really hits home dude to you
you know
not good
how long was that deployment that was a
six month round
and the iraqis took massive casualties
they before we left they were like the
special unit we were working with
and it trained up over the years the the
sf actually trained them up i think we
had a hand in the pie somewhere in there
but
they were dialed in they were the best
unit that the iraqis had and these guys
had a lot of pride but they were like
over 800 casualties uh when we left
and it was just it was i mean isis was
no joke over there man
they were they're barbaric brutal
and you know there's a there's a
fraction of
of people where you think you're going
to come in and you're going to talk
some sense into some people like that
you're not you're not talking to them
and if they get a hold of you it's not
going to be good for you you're going to
get your head
chopped off and that's the type of uh
that's what
that's what we're dealing with over
there and those you know that unit that
our guys were working with
they laid it all out there they were
going in there for their country for
iraq
to secure that city to make it a better
place and man they took
heavy casualties i mean heavy casualties
um
you know the the the truck bombs they
built
from 2004 to 2016 they up
armored them in 2016. so when they're
coming at you there's no way
there's not a good way to defeat them
you need some type of missile system a
rocket system coming in on top
or you need some type of arresting
device where you can stop the vehicle
from coming at you
um you know we had some good penetration
with some of our heavy caliber weapons
was stopping them but it was hard
it was not easy and they'd hide them
underneath
you know vehicle or or carport
um entry points and you wouldn't be able
to tell what it is next thing you know
that
big huge you know truck bomb is on the
move and there's up armored all over the
place and there's just a small window
that they can look out
and guess what if they come off the seat
or anything happens with the seat and
their adjustment
the things rig to just blow so as soon
as it hits something
the whole thing's going up and man we
just remember watching
cts units this damn thing would be
coming you'd be trying to call in an
airstrike
but you got like a minute and 30 seconds
to clear air space overhead
to get bombs down on targets it's like
it wasn't gonna happen
so you had to be able to handle business
as a tactical unit on the ground to take
this thing out
you know we'd give these guys rockets
and ship but it they weren't effective
um so it was a super complex and
frustrating
um environment you know and took a lot
of casualties
yeah i know uh jason was saying that
that you know at a certain point they
were thinking that the
iraqi unit that was doing the majority
of the fighting
was going to run out of guys like they
just weren't gonna they were just gonna
all be
dead or all be casualties which which
was
freaking scary and i i was horrified you
know when he was telling me that now
it's
i was hearing some of that while while
you guys were actually over there
but at the same time even though it kind
of horrified me at the same time
i also was this is going to sound wrong
but i was happy to hear it because
what it told me was that the iraqis were
fighting yeah
and when we were in ramadi the iraqis
they some of them would fight but it
definitely wasn't they weren't looking
to take massive casualties to try and
take a city back like they didn't care
that much
yeah and they would run away we had a
whole battalion
quit a whole battalion of iraqi soldiers
said yeah we're out
well we had one entire company disappear
like there was a
a strike on their on one of their
checkpoints
and they all just bailed that was that
yeah so to hear
how hard the iraqis were fighting and
they were taking it to isis and that
they were staying in the fight
that was just freaking um that was just
it was awesome to hear that it was so
horrible to hear that they were taking
casualties but it was great to hear
that they had found the will to fight
and that they were
unified and and fighting
courageously to to liberate other
iraqis inside their country from these
actual savages that are doing the most
committing the most heinous atrocities
imaginable
and and it was all it was awesome to
hear that they were that they were
fighting like that
and and it was also you know when when
isis decided to
you know wear a uniform and put up flags
it was like
right on yeah let's see how this works
out for you
yeah freaking legit uh
and then what then what so finish up
with with that deployment
get back off of that and then that's
when i rolled over to group one
and so you know started you know i got a
good six
six month of getting saturated with
group level stuff and you know with the
group you're responsible for all
you know four west coast sale teams and
three other commands so you got roughly
right around 1800 people or so
and your primary function there is
manning training and equipment so i'm
working directly with
the team command master chiefs um on
some occasions they're commanding
officers and so
you're in a position of a lot of
influence at that point you know and i'm
directly working with our commodore on
on our initiatives
and moving the mission forward and
you're also dealing with uh
whatever sort of you know uh equipment
like trying to get equipment for the
guys trying to
just the whole nine yards and and
overall
responsible for their training did you
go out to the desert during that time
went out there a couple times damn bro
and it's so it's weird it's different
when you're up at that
level when you come down in it's never
the same
yeah it's never you know you're the show
for you yeah you're the guy
then it's like hey i'm coming in there
to see this and you're like
hey man you guys might want to tighten
this [ __ ] up over here you know but um
it was good you know uh damn who was
there i think jay yeah jay was at trade
at the time
so it was good so jay was always there
as a right-hand man i had out there and
we had a good
crew of uh team committed master chiefs
and one of the things we started doing
back in
2015 with the the force i was working
with the forced command master chief
as he started implementing a screening
process so we were basically going
through
a hiring to make sure that we were
getting the right leaders
in at the the master chief level to take
over some of these command positions
and it's not perfect but it was a hell
of a lot better than where we were
um they also we also started
implementing in you know
platoon chief and task unit senior
listed advisor screening
and that was developing so it's uh it's
getting better as we move forward
bottom line is you know things are
getting better you're moving things
forward
that's what you want for a better
formation
you know and just going back to work on
real quick
one of the things i realized when you're
up there you know when you're down in
the troops
you're just like give me my gear i want
to get go to war and do all these things
and
people talk a lot of [ __ ] about everyone
above them and here's the deal with the
people that are above you
i'm you i'm you i was the e5 talking
that [ __ ] saying all those things
and guess what i moved up positions but
i moved up in positions to take care of
people
right and so there's a lot of kooky
things that come out you're the guy
behind the scenes
squashing these things you know to make
sure that that our people are taken care
of
and i always i had a buddy that was you
know he was a hard case and he's like
hey man why don't you ever say this
won't you
you need to stand up and say something
about that i'm like hey man i'm handling
that [ __ ] behind closed doors i'm not
going to come here and open forum
with the commander and disagree with
them in front of all these people man
that's not
that's not smart i'm getting nowhere
yeah but if i come around the back side
here do a little flank
plant some seeds you can have a lot more
influence that way
um so anyways you're always going to get
that [ __ ] with the hard cases you know
what i'm talking about yeah
and then how long was that tour so that
was a two-year tour you know when i
wanted to finish up my career there
and and and towards the end you're like
i mean what
what were you thinking what was on the
horizon and what was your
decision-making process to to
decide to punch punch yeah so i punched
right at like the 28 and a half year
mark so i could have gone another year
and a half but man i was out of juice
and one of the things people talk about
is hey you know when it's time to go
and man i was in that position and we
had some high profile cases out there
and they just wear on you man you know
they just wear on you and
even before that happened i knew it was
time for me to go i'm like all right i'm
going to do this position it's time for
me to
to move out of here i don't think i had
anything left to add value
to the mission in the organization i was
topped out with my leadership capacity
and we have
plenty of guys that go out there and do
the the t-socks you know the theater
special operations command and that's a
high level
of influence those are action arms in
the operational
uh areas and i was like man i just don't
see myself
going and working at that level you're
working with general officers with
admirals and i was like man i just
and i was up a war com kind of got a a
little bit of a taste of that
and i was like that's just not me um and
we need people to do those positions so
we had quite a few east coast guys going
in uh and into those t-shock positions
and you need them because that's a huge
a high level of influence that the that
we have in nsw
if you have your guy in there he can
help influence some outcomes which is
super important but i was definitely
maxed out uh
out of gas time for me to pack up and go
home
and one of the things that always uh it
comes to mind
with me is in 2003
you know we had posey out there our
vietnam guy good dude man good family
guy vietnam had
more stores you can imagine but he was
like man
steve you guys are stronger faster
smarter than than we ever were i was
like damn what's he talking about and
then i look back
you know 28 you know what 15 years later
or whatever it was
and i'm like these young guys that are
coming in they're hungry
they're smarter they're stronger than i
was they're faster than i was
meaning hey the community's in a good
spot we got our next generation
coming up in through our ranks doing
good things
you know one of the things uh one of our
head leaders for the navy put out
mick pawn stevens he said hey work hard
stay out of trouble and be a good person
that's all i'm asking the formation to
do the entire navy that's that was his
mantra
work hard stay out of trouble be a good
and cue be a good decent
human being be a good person and i never
knew what the hell he meant by stay out
of trouble and then
you know as you start moving up in these
positions and you have high profile
cases and things going on
they can bring your entire community
down to its knees meaning it's hard to
move initiatives forward it's hard to
to focus on what your actual job is
because you're dealing with
you know in jp you're dealing with court
martials all those things weigh on you
and it's never good
and my boss in 2015 are forced he
he hammered it home to me and it made
sense he said hey steve
we've got to protect the mission we've
got to protect our credibility
credibility that's built in other
people's blood it was spilled in other
people's blood
we've got to protect that at all cost
and he's like it's hard for us to
protect the homeland
if we if our credibility's damaged and
we can't get employed overseas to wrap
up bad guys
i was like yeah check that ship makes
sense
so yeah yeah well that's it's the same
thing as a reputation right yeah
the community has a reputation and you
got to do everything you can to protect
that reputation
yeah because if you're if you're yeah
just that's just what you have to do
yeah you know and you do your best you
do everything you can to protect your
reputation i mean that's just what you
got to do
you know man
any other uh echo you got anything
said something about a firecracker
earlier like a firecracker
scenario or whatever and you were like
oh you got the firecracker
like right off the bat or something like
that like that
it was the nickname for an area in
ramadi
that was north of route michigan
and it was this little road that wrapped
up and around us called firecracker and
the reason it was called firecracker was
because
there was a lot of bad [ __ ] going on
here there was a lot of fire
a lot of fire cracking off as you said
yeah
interesting okay and that was like your
first that was our first
uh operation in uh ramadi dude that's a
welcome to ramadi
situation right there damn yeah it was
good
that was good that's the line freaking
crazy
anything else steve any closing thoughts
no that's it right oh man
well uh thanks for coming on man yeah
oh you know what i'll say one more thing
at one point probably you were like
six months out from retiring and you
said i have three courses of action for
what i'm gonna do when i get out
echelon front echelon front echelon
front i was like right old man
freaking awesome uh which is a rip-off
from the marine that i covered the book
on the podcast
where when he was getting ready to
graduate from
the basic school yeah and they had to
fill out what they wanted to do
and this was in 1967. they had to fill
out what they wanted to do in the marine
corps
and he put one two three infantry
platoon commander in chief platoon
commander infantry platoon commander
it's like that's what i'm gonna do
i was like roger that all right guess
we're gonna execute on this thing
so it's freaking awesome thanks for what
you did to the teams
for the teams obviously for america
obviously
and and and for freedom and i know we
had an awesome time working together in
the past i've
i still i just when i drive at night
whenever i drive at night especially out
here in california in the desert
i'm always thinking i'm driving back
from from the desert from our desert
training facility
and just with just totally amped
because i wouldn't be able to sleep
because i'd be so fired up for the teams
and for the boys and i'd be like just
amped driving back
knowing that we made some freaking guys
ready for war
so it was awesome working with you then
and uh awesome working with you again
right now man
yeah hey i really appreciate it i'm glad
to be on with with echelon front
it's uh it's awesome can i say one thing
real quick yeah
yeah i'd like to thank my wife allison
she's put up with me for all these years
she's prior military good southern girl
from arkansas
um and she runs a tight game she keeps
me
she keeps me in line so i love worth all
my heart she's an awesome person and uh
my kids i love you guys right old man
awesome
well uh echo yes sir
speaking of
getting after it speaker speaking of
being awesome
what do you think we can do to uh become
more awesome
to strive strive strive for awesomeness
at the very least how about that
strategy there's some podcast we did
from some ancient warrior shaking the
world
shaking the world with your awesomeness
oh yeah oh
well you know that's a that's a big step
she's going
striving to shaking the world like
that's that's kind of a big step for
sure so let's start with striving
cool good all right well hey
in your path to strive for awesomeness
or in the event that you're just
straight up trying to shake the world
with awesomeness hey
look you might need some supplementation
okay let me let me start this but steve
you know you listen to the podcast
yes um how often do you listen to this
part of the podcast
what percentage of time i
i'm probably 50 50 you you hang on or is
it just you can't hit
stop on your freaking iphone so you just
have to roll with it it's like stuff
there's so many new products coming out
you've got to listen to it to kind of go
all right is there some new line coming
out here i'm not tracking
oh chad it's true he makes it good so so
he's saying 50
my guess is he's kind of rounding up to
be nice because you know he doesn't want
to be like harsh to equity
that's cool all lady is one percent
that's only that's right man he's here
at 50. she does 49. here's what i know i
just got a text from jp and uh and uh
dave burke they want to know if you're
gonna talk about their discipline go
some sour apple snipel
you mean good deal dave good deal dave
okay jp just
just tracking on it yeah like tracking
that steve's here
and then sending taking the time to send
a text to say hey make sure you talk
about sour apple sniper
okay dave dave wants to make jp jealous
so you got to mention dave's uh
afterburner
okay no problem we're on it fully
so these two guys are just breaking in
the game that's all man
that's how and i dig it either way
before we get to the discipline or
discipline go
which are you know they're kind of
different but kind of the same we talk
about
joint supplements it's important because
you don't want to think about this kind
of stuff while we're trying to
what shake the world with you know we're
thinking awesomeness or strive or
whatever you know you don't want to
think about your joints
you don't want to think about your
immunity getting sick all this kind of
stuff so you take these supplements
joint warfare
joints super krill oil joints
vitamin d3 immunity and general health
by the way
vitamin d3 is good for a lot of stuff
all kinds
especially at this moment in time in
particular we're talking about
factual information about the glory of
the vitamin d
that's true absolutely true also uh cold
war
immunity supplement keep those in mind
so you don't have to keep the other
stuff in mind well yeah that's what i
you've you've finally gotten through to
me it's only taken 260 episodes
of uh now i understand that you're like
oh it's good
to to not have to think about your
joints bothering you
yes that's a good thing that is a good
thing so now i understand
you we don't want to wake up and be like
i hope my joints hold up today and
work out or whatever you see what i'm
saying yes you just want to go into the
workout warm up people
get it done as they say exactly right
also we have supplement called
discipline to supplement
for your brain for your body for your
whole thing really
life your life man your life powder
take discipline powder instead of coffee
try that
good coffee it could be something that's
what i'm saying as far as the routine
also discipline go which
are and or should i say were capsules
to begin with they are capsules if
you're on the go see what i'm saying
yes you did that they're they're they're
very popular
at echelon front yeah hey can i say
something on the discipline go capsules
hey so i've been using that stuff and so
when i'm going in and i'm doing a
speaking engagement that's why they're
so popular
i take two and here's the deal like when
i'm communicating
when i'm not taking that stuff it's like
i'm going down the highway and i
i really have to think hard about the
words i'm gonna communicate it's like
the words are in
off the shoot off a street when i'm on
the discipline go the words are right
there
on the road i'm going 60 miles an hour
you're like boom boom boom
clear concise communications and i don't
know what's in it but it definitely
clears up your mind
it clears up your mind it works you got
to get i'm telling you if you're a boss
you got some things going on a meeting a
high-speed meeting
you're talking to people it helps i
promise you it helps i wouldn't i
wouldn't say if it did yeah
no that's why that's why at echelon
front where we get up and we have to not
only we have to speak but we gotta
take questions interpret questions we
gotta come up with answers and solutions
and so the team is always like yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna i wanna bring the a game
right
yep how do you ensure you bring the a
game take a little discipline go
and then if you have like a little more
time or maybe you want to enjoy that a
little bit more
you can get a can of discipline go yes
which is
what you mentioned right many flavors
now shoot the flavor roster getting big
over here
so most recently after burner orange
good deal dave burke boom before that
sour apple sniper jp denelle what are
they competing with each other
oh good lord there's some competition
before that
jackal palmer which by the way which by
the way jocko palmer
jocko palmer is not jocko palmer what it
is
is it's 50 50 iced tea lemonade
that's what it is yeah some people were
thinking it was pomegranate because we
also have choco pomegranate
white tea yeah which which you probably
remember steve
tell us about that's the origin story
right there at an island
me rolling into those briefs with that
big old plastic uh
uh protein shaker with freaking
with with pomegranate tea which i would
get from wherever and then i'd just sit
there in the front row and they'd give
their brief and
check back to just take your notes and
be like
all right you give your points
or actually like you know whatever the
the frontline instructors would give
their points then you'd give your points
and then
be like you'd be like you got anything
boss and i'm like
a couple things is there caffeine there
is
just a little bit yeah there's a little
by the whole thing yeah so speaking of
caffeine
and just a little bit yes jocko palmer
that was the one before that and then
before that was what
who's the first signature oh jack savage
the first signature was back savage yeah
dakota
tasty is that your go-to what's your
go-to
i like the dak savage and i like the
story behind dak savage
yeah dude he's a monster if you can just
get a little if you can have a little
bit of
mentality of dakota then your
your whole your whole being is better
yeah
no not no offense to jp and dave i don't
know i want to have their mentalities
too
but let's face it it's dak savage it's
freaking dakota we're kind of in the
game
dakotas kind of take do you did you
drink dr pepper when you were a kid
i did not because that's kind of the
yeah it's kind of the flavor apparently
it's tasty yeah that's tasty yeah that's
my that's my wife's
favorite yeah which what do you think of
that dakota i see you tracking on my
life
tracking on my wife dakota uh yeah so
that one's kind of a
sour apple sniper is i'm gonna say if
you have a little bit of a sweet tooth
yeah probably sour apple sniper is your
go-to
it's true jacquel palmer is is if you
like iced tea and lemonade
yeah that was my favorite before the
orange the orange is your favorite
currently my favorite yeah yes sir but
hey man you know to each their own
and you know we're going to move forward
so what this is though discipline go
in a can energy drink health energy
drink healthy energy drink
no health drink in the form of an energy
drink yeah
it's been hard to figure out what to
call it
whatever you were just saying steve was
pretty legit about just
going down the road finding words
everything's in focus and i'm like yeah
dude
i know what your feeling is yeah and
that's what makes like the the can so
good because you know
like let's face it you're just doing
whatever during the day
whatever we do during the day you're
like oh you know i'll grab a water i'll
grab a
juice grab a soda sometimes
some of us no this this exactly right
though
this is like you can grab it no you
don't get the bad parts of soda yeah you
know i mean yeah if you're going for a
water cool man
do it but if you're grabbing like a red
bull or i shouldn't say
any particular brand but if you're
grabbing a soda or an
energy drink i'm just saying you're
gonna pay a price for that you're paying
a price
you're paying a price with your health
yeah and and with this discipline go
it's paying you you think you would
think that somebody would have already
made
an equivalent right you would think
you'd think that it's real obvious
hey i'm going to make something that
makes you enhances your performance but
it's actually good for you
you'd think somebody would have done
that why didn't they do it
number one cost too much and now they're
now they're not making they're not
maximizing profits at the freaking
cash register yeah that's true and
number two is hard
yeah it was hard to do because we had to
instead of just throwing a bunch of
chemicals in there so it wouldn't go bad
we had to pasteurize it
which no one does no so there you go
and not only that hey how are you gonna
make it taste good well we'll just put a
bunch of chemicals in there that
that are bad for you but they'll make
people taste good and we don't care
about the people that we're serving this
to
so we'll just let them drink poison
we'll just let them drink poison what
did we do we said no i was like no we're
not doing that
we're gonna sweeten it with something
real it's monk fruit
so that's why he doesn't even that
doesn't seem like a lot of barriers to
entry right like hey we're gonna
pasteurize it
we're gonna put we're gonna sweeten it
naturally we're gonna only put healthy
ingredients in it
you'd think that those those bars to
entry aren't that high
you'd think someone would have done it
but they didn't yeah they didn't do it
so we did amen like i said now everyone
else can get in line
as far as getting in line goes for sure
also speaking of tasting good
milk superior protein in the form of
a dessert so you know um you know
such a good dessert yeah very much so so
uh brian i don't even know if i'm
supposed to say this but brian sends
my son and me i'm more of a secondary
thing
but it sends my son milk bars oh yeah
right i don't know if they're still in
the experimental stage
or whatever the version that you're
getting right now is pretty close to a
done deal
yeah yeah so it's like it's one of those
things where yeah man
if you want a dessert like milk is the
dessert
and it's super as far as like um you
know how like sometimes you're like oh i
need a dessert but i
you know i'm on the path so i'm gonna
have a dessert substitute or something
like this
what i'm saying you had those out i
thought those were out already
i was in bars yeah i was eating
something back in uh december
last year we were we were in the
experimental phase well they were tasty
then yeah
they've gotten better wow they've gotten
better so it's been hard man
it's been really hard there's enough
it's the same it's the same kind of
battles you're fighting with the like
with with making the drink and how do
you actually keep it stable
there's more there's more there's well
not more but there's different things in
play trying to make a bar how do you
keep it stable how does it maintain its
texture over time
what happens when it's sitting on the
shelf for two months there's a bunch of
things to deal with
so we find in the version that you're
getting right now echo we finally
figured out how to overcome all that and
do it naturally
and make it taste good and have the
right flavor profile
and stay stable on the shelf so it's
been a long road
it's been a road that we almost backed
away from and you know me i'm not one to
d-o-r-d-o-r as they say
sure yeah but either way yes milk
protein informative
dessert not a dessert substitute by the
way
just simply dessert straight up where do
you get all this stuff
origin main.com originally
originally there's many other places to
get it but before we go there
okay let's go here choco white t you
mentioned the pomegranate white tea
chocolate tea
that is available we're not just talking
about draco used to drink
white tea now he doesn't bruh drinks
even better white tea
i had it away yeah remember you still
drink it in that big
jar just to bring the big juice oh i
used to bring it even
back in the day like a crazy person yeah
yeah
nonetheless yes that's available as well
at orgyman.com
also at the vitamin shop offline
what do you call it like
brick-and-mortar yeah
boom vitamin shop go get it also the
discipline go
cans are at wawa in florida currently
yeah and by the way if you live in
florida and you've been and
look i i asked and said hey please this
is the mission
we wanna we wanna go into the full chain
of wawa
we needed to go hard in florida we
needed to go in there and clear
shelves well you all that have been
clearing shelves thank you
keep going we're on the path to victory
don't let up that's true keep getting
after it
because you know why because people in
pennsylvania and new jersey
and maryland they're they're counting on
florida
it's all eyes on florida we got a rock
and roll in florida we're on the right
path
don't let up bruh it it's true and that
the thing is again i said this before
it's kind of a big deal though to
go and get like an energy drink or
whatever and it'd be legitimate healthy
for you
is a huge deal when you eat like you
didn't even really have to think about
but but
you just went back i mean we were
talking about that 15 minutes ago but
we're talking about it again
that's cool i don't think i i
capitalized not capitalized
i broke down the entire thing about the
bars and the thing we got to do and how
hard it was
but that wasn't good enough but not
about the price you pay when you when
you take
drink an energy drink or a soda or
something like this that price you pay
versus the price that you don't pay
that's a big deal i didn't think i
maximized
the uh how should i say the
communication of that big deal check
i think i have now okay also at origin
main.com is american-made stuff
jiu-jitsu stuff geez rash cards some uh
some athletics let me ask you a question
can you wear a ghee when you go to the
grocery mart grocery market
yeah well as far as grocery marts go
yeah sure i mean you could
technically advisable well you know i'm
i'm not gonna sit here and advise that
but
man if you're gonna do it go ahead do
that okay
was there something that we could wear
that would be more acceptable sure
like what maybe some jeans ah there we
go there we go
maybe i don't know but baby yes but
where can you get american-made jeans
you know it's very hard um oh how should
i say as far as uh
options go there are not as many options
as you know one might hope
but thankfully yes i am here to tell you
at origenmaine.com you can get
american-made
denim jeans you know what
you probably are thinking if you're an
american you're probably thinking about
like
iconic iconic
i'm gonna say three words iconic
american
genes and we all know there's a few
brands that fall into that category
they've been around for a long time
iconic american jeans
i got news for you you're iconic
american jeans
they're not american they're not
american brutal
so if you want to get iconic american
jeans i'll tell you where you go
you go to origenmaine.com and you get
yourself some
iconic american jeans we're bringing
them back
yes sir yeah good work they're doing
some good work over there at
origin speaking of good work joco has a
store
it's called jocko store obviously so
joggerstore.com that's where you can get
your discipline equals freedom shirts
hoodies hats bunch of stuff on there
really cool stuff
in my opinion see if it's your opinion
too chocolate store.com oh also
we do have a t-shirt club kind of
creative you can come up with something
else to call this besides t-shirt club
uh yeah okay please obviously i have
that capability sure
uh i don't know t-shirt platoon
t-shirt brigade t-shirt
gang we'll just say see what i'm saying
you rolled right into
something that like you know my 11 year
old daughter
has a roller skating club right you see
where i'm going with this
tighten yourself up bro
it's a working title and we're doing our
best over here nonetheless
this is what it is it's a subscription
based situation where you get a shirt
new shirt
every month creative designs anyway
check that one out too if you're
interested boom
do that good for a gift too by the way
there you go jocklestore.com also
subscribe oh wait wait we have
other podcasts you didn't even mention
this podcast
well we're on this podcast okay we do
have other podcasts oh guess what the
podcast you're listening to it's a
podcast
it exists yeah we already know that we
don't gotta mention that okay so
yeah uh yeah subscribe to all these
different podcasts jocko podcast
jocko unraveling podcast grounded
podcast and warrior kid podcast
check those out leave a review
sure because they're funny if you leave
a review make it entertaining
put some layers in it it's appreciated
yeah
past reviews have been pretty impressive
you know what i haven't done for a while
has read reviews
like online or re-posting i got to do
that
those are awesome it's true i'll do some
of that also
also we have a youtube channel uh video
version is podcast
you know you want to see what steve ward
looks like handsome guy i would say
as far as handsome guys go but
nonetheless if you want to see what
thank you echo and you're welcome of
course
but nonetheless yes and we have some
excerpts on there you want to you know
watch slash listen to those uh that's
where that's what you can get on the
youtube channel official by the way
we got it youtube boom also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album
jocko's album with tracks not music
album
not yet not yet we're working it yes
anyway it's an album with tracks of
jocko helping you through a moment of
weakness like we're gonna skip the
workout
there's a little track on there to help
you not skip the workout put simply
that's what it is
flipsidecanvas.com speaking of dakota
meyer
he's got a a company where he prints
cool stuff to hang on your wall that's
all you need to say
check that out flipsidecamas.com got a
bunch of books
we talked about one of them today we
talked about a couple of them today but
about face by colonel david hackworth
highly recommended there's a new version
that has
a forward in it written by me
how freaking stoked i was to do that man
that's awesome did i tell you that how
that happened
no they were so it started selling again
kind of like when i started talking
about it all the time
and so they eventually pulled the thread
and tried to figure out why it was
selling and they eventually figured out
was selling because
we were talking about all the time on
the podcast and um
they wrote me and said hey do you want
to write we're going to re-release it
do you want to write a blurb for the
back which is like a little quote like
hey this is a great book
and i wrote them and said uh i'll write
can i write a forward to it and they'd
be like you want to write a forward and
i said hell yeah i'll write a forward to
it
most forwards are about 500 words if you
google like how long should a book
forward be
it should be about 500 words my forward
for this is 5000 words
yeah it's like a freaking because i just
went off and explained
how i found it what it meant you know
all these the lessons i learned from it
and so yeah it's been it's been awesome
so if you want to
check out that book about face by
colonel david hackworth
then go ahead and check that out also
leadership strategy and tactics
field manual so good
you what you just had a company that
told you uh what they just said
yeah we so they'd already they read
extreme ownership
and their leadership team has them they
have the dichotomy of leadership and i
was like hey do you guys have leadership
strategies and tactics
and they one of them purchased it
they're like yeah
they're inbound we got them for the
whole team now and the beautiful thing
with it is is
you got an issue you can find it in that
book with a a good solution
and it might not be 100 solution for
your situation but you can take that
formulate it and utilize it that's the
beauty of that thing
yeah so powerful that's exactly the what
i had in mind when i wrote it was
can you look up in here okay let me go
i'm having a problem with my subordinate
how do i do what do i do
you know i'm having a problem with
people getting on board with the new
plan what do i do
and just be able to look it up in there
find the solution
the beautiful thing about it is you
don't even have to tab it
because the answers are up front hey
you're having this issue flip to this
page
in one to two pages you find your answer
you read through it digest it boom
implement it so easy check uh
the code the evaluations the protocol if
you
need some guidance on where to go look
in the military we
got told hey you're slacking a little
here you could do a little better here
but we go through life without an
evaluation of ourselves
how do you expect to know where to go
get the code the evaluation the protocol
get the discipline equals freedom field
manual new version
bigger picture of my head therefore you
know
obviously better another 35 or 40 pages
of writing in there
ideal i'm gonna say it i don't like to
throw that out there
but kind of an ideal gift book right
it's not just like oh i went to the
bookstore and i randomly found this book
over here called whatever
it's like i got something with a little
substance it's a little bigger
it's a little heavier looks cool looks
cool
you can put it on a table and just have
it be there just and if you read it
you're doing even better
yes sir what up okay
so i got this you gave me a signed copy
a few years ago oh
but i'm just trying to see what the
difference is oh yeah well the
difference is there's about
40 extra pages of where i wrote more
stuff gotcha more information so there's
that
and then also there's way of the warrior
kid
for field manual which is what your kid
wants for christmas that's what your kid
wants
for christmas because all these lessons
that we talk about look you can learn
them when you're 40
after you read freaking leadership
strategy and tactics
or you can learn them when you're seven
and you can go through life
understanding these things
and you can end up in a much better
place so what do you can do with your
kid
you're going to put them on a path to
mediocracy
mediocrity are you going to put your kid
on a path to being average
are you going to be put your kid on a
path to blame other people and be a
victim their whole life
or are you going to put them on the bath
path to be a warrior kid and step up
i'll tell you what i recommend weigh the
warrior kid for a field manual
go ahead and get some of that also weigh
the warrior kid one
two and three mikey and the dragons oh
you know what kids have to deal with
being afraid
and it's not just kids but why not learn
at a young age
how to overcome fear get mikey and the
dragons
and also extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership
the og books did i say og
yes sir yes i did we also have echelon
front
it's our leadership consultancy it's
steve's with us now on the team how long
you been on the team for
march officially march i've been yeah
you know ever since i got out i've been
kind of
shadowing dave and some of the crew so
so
if you wanna if you if you want to work
with us if you want help aligning your
leadership if you wanna learn the
lessons that we learned if you want us
to come in
and help your leadership get aligned
help find where the friction points are
help figure out where you can be more
efficient as a team
go to echelonfront.com we solve problems
through leadership we also have ef
online
which is where we solve problems through
leadership online and we're on there all
the time
so if you if you want to if you want to
come on there and you want to ask
me a question you want to ask me a
question you might think uh
how could i ever ask jock a question
it's easy you go to ef online you can
ask me a question i'll be sitting right
there you want to ask steve a question
about how he handled a certain situation
how he organized platoons
how he put teams together how he handled
these leadership challenges go on to
efonline.com
and you can ask steve a question he's
literally be sitting there
so check that out efonline.com we have
the muster we're scheduling the muster
for 2021. go to extremeownership.com for
details we have ef overwatch if you want
people that understand these principles
to come and work at your company go to
eforewatch.com
and we have people that we're
transitioning from the military to the
civilian sector
and they'll come to your company and
work and if you want to help service
members
active and retired service members their
families gold star families around the
world
check out mark lee's mom mark lee's
mom's
organization mama lee she's got a group
called america's mighty warriors
and if you want to donate or get
involved then go to
americasmightywarriors.org
and if you let's say you just desire
anguish and pain in your life
in your own life we can give it to you
if you want it we can give it to you
if you want more of my mundane
discourse
or you need more of echo's unfathomable
phraseology and you can find us on the
interwebs
on twitter on instagram which echo only
refers to as the gram
and on facebook echo is adequate charles
and i am at jacka willink where you at
steve i'm at steve ward 194.
steve 194. or whatever on instagram on
instagram
instagram steve.ward194
is that how it works that answer what do
do you post anything so i i'll probably
will here
soon it's hunting season have you posted
have you posted anything
ah no what are you hunting for ducks
right on it's fun yeah and it's good
living
it's good living not as good eating as
elk
or deer but you're gonna get what you
can get we're gonna get what we can get
check uh yeah steve man
thanks for coming back on it's coming on
it's freaking awesome
and uh appreciate everything everything
man yeah
everything and thanks to all of our
other
military personnel right now
out in the world on watch as steve said
you you all are smarter and stronger
and faster and more well equipped and
better trained than we ever were
so thanks for uh holding it down make
sure you train up the people underneath
you
and for our police and law enforcement
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all first responders
well thanks for protecting us here at
home and to everyone else out there
you know steve talked a lot today about
setting a good example
modeling the right example
and you'll also notice that almost every
phase of his life he talked about
learning and how he learned
well i would say that's part of that
good example is don't ever stop learning
don't ever stop growing don't ever stop
trying to
improve you can only do that if you stay
humble
so stay humble listen learn
and lead and also make sure
that you keep getting after it
and until next time this is steve and
echo
and jocko out